this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised a very good often everybody and
everyone and a very warm welcome also to
our sunset Safari Drive all the way from
the Kruger National Park in South Africa
and see what we are trying to show you
are we showing you today how exciting is
that to start with a huge male kuru my
name is always david and joined the
camera money come on money the camera is
fog always always fog and i can say he's
one of the best cameraman we got here
and just see what i think he's one of
the greatest and there's a male kuru
they're trying to cut a femur there and
remember we request all of you to know
this is always a very interactive safari
your questions your comments and your
feelings make a huge difference so keep
tweeting on hashtag safari live and you
can always follow us on the YouTube chat
stream very lucky to start with kudos on
a great afternoon with 74 degrees very
good with 74 degrees Fahrenheit and 20
oops 23 degrees Celsius I don't know why
she was running there and I was just
telling the men could where they
couldn't watch the mail go with a man
somewhere fog because I won't tell this
many milk ooh happy Father's Day
Melkor ooh see by telling him that his
trying to mark his territory and to all
of you nice viewers whoever you are in
the world for those who did not meet me
in the morning I'm telling you very
happy Father's Day to the koodoo fathers
to the fathers of the spiders to the
fathers from the crocodiles to the
fathers from the snakes in all the
father's in the wilderness all over the
world happy Father's Day
ouch with me today we have the gentleman
who is doing work and getting all the
trucks rough and we got the beautiful
girl Taylor McCrory out somewhere doing
what I'm doing and we're promising you
another exciting Sunset Drive it's
majestic kudu walking away can see how
they keep matching in the open area
which is a quarantine area as much as
their browsers once in a while you'll
get them coming out and eating some
little Ferb's or plants on the ground
and they said earlier the beautiful girl
Taylor would like to say hello to all of
you
good afternoon hello everybody as David
said my name is Taylor mccurdy and on
camera with me today is Greg and we are
looking for cheetah cats are we gonna
finally always get that stuff every
single time I don't think I've ever
avoided the stuff that scores on the
road I always drive over it anyways as I
said we are looking for cheetah today
and we're gonna find them seen as though
they've been around for last two drives
which has been fantastic
well I'll like last all today I hope so
I really hope so I've been wanting to
see them and then I was of course I
suppose the cheetah were teasing me by
leading me on a wild goose chase
yesterday morning and then well taunting
me with a view on foot which was pretty
spectacular but I do like to watch those
youngsters play around and they're very
rec relaxed around the cars so let's
keep our fingers crossed they have moved
though they moved them I think they well
I've had tracks going down Zoe's Road
that look really fresh on top of the
vehicle tracks from this morning so I
assume that they've come this way now
I'm just trying to figure out where
they've gone off so her bein the bush
walk team have also joined us hoping to
give us a hand so I'm just going to
check this intersection very quickly
yeah I actually want to go check this
open area first let's quickly do that
because there's a nice open area ya
don't see any tracks coming this way
it's actually quite warm I don't know
why I have my jersey on now that is not
a good representation of what the
weather is actually actually like it's
going to have to come off I'm afraid at
some point and I'm not starting to feel
like I'm developing a fever but that's
of course because I'm just warming up
with this silly Jersey on definitely
quite difficult
trying to track and and then also spot
the animals it's so difficult ones quite
an ass in the morrow you could just look
around and scan a bit
thank you Jason and I think that's
motivating me to want to find the chichi
you said if I find the cheesy you will
kiss me through your iPad thank you
that's very kind
there we go you can have a kiss back
no no if people do that but they okay
let us try and find the cheetah cats
okay now I've got distracted thanks
Jason
and we're gonna keep looking for the
cheetah or go to Ralph's to see where he
is
good afternoon everybody and welcome
welcome to the afternoon bush walk and
well my name is ralph kirsten and we're
coming to you live from the Graduate
Kruger National Park in South Africa on
the camera today I've got sins eye with
me and please don't forget to send us
your questions and your comments on the
hashtag Safari live on Twitter and on
the youtube live chat because we'd love
to know what you would like to find out
this afternoon about well whatever you
want out here in the bush now we've
decided to just go along and help Tyler
to relocate those skank Hank as we call
him here locally or the cheetah those
three cheetah because they were seen
this morning but um seems like they've
moved along a little bit so we're also
gonna head in that direction and see if
we can pick up on any of those fresh
tracks and then just point them in the
right direction after that however we
will then go and see if we can maybe
catch up with Tandy and play Lamba or
with tingoora whatever is sort of the
most the the more productive of the two
for us to be able to go and find and
that's in terms of the freshness of
checks and where exactly those two
different characters are in terms of
where you know the the kind of Bush that
they're in so the one that is most
realistic to be able to find will go and
hid there at the moment just walking and
enjoying this lovely long yellow
fetching grass as this grass is used in
a lot of the hats and homebuilding here
in the area so this would obviously be
harvested outside of a national
lots of the ladies go and collect this
they also sell it mixed to the roads and
obviously the people using that to build
their hats with these round round oval
top concrete walls with the grass
hitting up on the top it's a very
fascinating now let's see what do you
guys want us to look at in terms of the
small things as we go along on the walk
you can let us know please bronec you
say you want to see some snakes I'll try
my best to show you some checks of
snakes but at this time of year in
winter not as much activity of snakes
than you would get in summer so
obviously there are ectothermic as you
do know so sometimes it's we can find
them at this time of day just sunning
themselves a little bit and I'll try my
best as I say to see if we can find some
maybe we'll find some lizards as well
good time of the day for them to be
trying to get a bit of warmth and a
little bit earlier we had quite a bit of
spattering of rain so it might have
cleared up some of the checks in some of
the pots and at least we'll be able to
have a nice Tomlin - now it's fun we've
got extremely fresh tracks or not
because since this morning
obviously we'll have just a little bit
of a splashing on the roads and on the
sand from the water that was that came
through it was just a quick cloud burst
not too much rain all together almost
wanted one of those winter sort of rain
showers quick quick and then it was gone
so you can see still a few rain clouds
around but I think it's pretty much
burning off for the moment so we're just
gonna continue I think heading towards
where those cheetah were last seen and
I'm pretty sure that with a bit of luck
we'll be able to find him
fantastic and good luck you got a job to
do there off to get a snake for an
overview uh sir hopefully you get one
and we moved on we left the kudos and
now we have found a new species of
antelopes young ones males and females
have been trained to look specifically
for the males and tell them happy
Father's Day but they are not separating
they are all staying together and these
are the fun bits the wildebeest having a
small mini migration I am trying to
imagine if they know where their cousins
are will be moving in the hundreds of
thousands and maybe another one or two
months in East Africa they used to be
also migration around this area way back
fantastic move from finer control haze
that's a great light and of course all
the credit goes to Fogg he sets a team
player and there's a great job we're
gonna move forward a little bit what do
you think [ __ ] and see because we have
seen this together with kudos and see
whether we can frame them together you
know you can have one film and short for
two and we have seen another set of
kudos with your huge Hans
we never miss looking on the ground
because that's where the trucks will
always be there's a waterhole not very
far from where we are and we have
noticed animals of different species
will be brought together about certain
commonalities water food sometimes
safety so this particular two different
species here are being brought at this
particular point by water
let's see fog you let me know where to
stop
exactly okay and this is look at that
how are you today and you're asking can
the world and must catch a flu or a cold
yes
as you can see that big hard of kudus
moving there they do they do depending
if they rain down definitely just like
human beings they're all mammals and we
are all subject to getting infections
yes they can and once in a while we also
hear or see animals sneezing you know
not once we are watching Lions who
cheetahs and you just hear a small
little sneeze so yes they can get cold
they can get fever they can get
infections for about my bonnet of the
car they can get you know even tuba
classes TVs we have seen Lions eating
buffaloes that are infected with some
tuba crosses and they get infected also
but somehow they come through as
beautiful kudos are much in their not
should is like a breeding season for
them this one dominant guy there and
he's definitely up to something cynic
how are you and always a pleasure to
hear your name and you're asking whether
kudos are the strongest antelopes I
think cynic it will depend on how you
look at it Oh strong in terms of
fighting strong in terms of you know
pushing trees but personally I think a
fully-grown Carew scenic of about 500
600 pounds or 550 pounds by any standard
they are huge and if you see two
fighting
you can tell if they miss each other on
a fight how they break the trees so I
would say well you know they're very
strong because one of the differences
and especially for the males
is fighting both say the strong strong
animals and most of the mayors you can
see baying browsers how the feeder
leaves they have a little bit of
advantage over the other antelopes
they can raise their long necks not like
the giraffes but we have the advantage
of reaching lay leaves the up there
unlike impalas or Daniela's Daniela's
are also browsers but they are not as
high or as tall as the kudos so at least
to me the last few weeks I've seen kudos
looking in better shape they are looking
Gousha
but the Kudus to me look more better and
one of the reasons i would say that is
they can reach the top leaves and you
can see ox because as usual hitchhiking
on them and getting all the parasites or
they you know or the ticks you may be
seeing on top of the screws fantastic
very good the scooters have done a very
good job and you'll have one more look
on someone bits here and then let's have
you do one move for that's good alright
we'll have a look at the one bits
they're all been feeling together but
you know birds of a feather fly it
together the kudos as a species all of
them shifted to the right and they moved
and the wildebeest have remained here
showing the differences between those
two species especially when it comes to
feeding habits this one's being more of
grazers but I'm sure they could be
getting something different from the
grass because as you can see the grass
there looks question dry but sometimes
to get the rhizomes the base of the
grass will always be holding some
nutrition and either the roots the good
masses or on the on the mouth we can be
able to approach here little roots or
pass down there
Rhonda you're wondering about the
dryness of the grass now we are going
through winter here now and maybe for
the next two months one that will not
get any rains and we hope to get trained
anytime maybe end of I would say forgot
I think end of July or August yeah very
good so far things was the end of August
September is when we express the rains
to come and everything here will turn
around and will be green but that
notwithstanding the animals have always
adapted and you can see that is very
good-looking Verna bestia Wanda and you
know very healthy they'll always know
how to substitute from the grass not
available they'll always know what to
substitute and feed on pretty small hard
compared to the hosta to migration and
how fantastic and every species are we
seeing today before I leave them I leave
them by saying as roughly circular tree
and live them by saying happy Father's
Day and let's find out if ruff is
telling trees happy Father's Day
well that's it is Happy Father's Day to
everybody around and I think it's only
in South Africa that it's Father's Day
because isn't it that different
countries have different days for
Father's Day
anyway it's Father's Day in South Africa
now so happy Father's Day from me to all
those father's out there to my father
and well here we go we standing here
next to a silver class the leaf us blue
tells me it's Father's Day worldwide I
do know that with Mother's Day there's a
couple of different days around the
world not international now these little
balls that we scene from the silver
cluster leaf I'm sure lots of people do
know what they are or any regular
viewers I'm sure this has been covered a
few times but for anybody that doesn't
know first and foremost obviously the
plant being called the silver cluster
leaf terminalia
sericea and it's very characteristic
tree that we
do you get and why it's called the
silver cast leaf is because of that
Sheen on the back
a hairy color giving it a silver
coloration on the back of the leaves and
class the leaf because all the Leafs are
sort of clustered up on the terminal bud
on the end of branches now that's not
the reason why I stopped yeah it's
because these cheese the cut
characteristic that they get stung by
gol wasps and the the little wasp then
actually injects a growth hormone into
the into the branches now I've pulled
one off an old one but I want to show
you one just on the plant itself there
it is there so little and that's quite a
big one the wasp will sting the branch
and then it grows into this bulb top
structure and it lays its eggs on the
inside there and then those eggs will
hatch obviously and pupate into the wasp
which later you will see these little
holes that they actually make the exit
now I just took this one off because I
just wanted to pop it open and we have a
look on the inside and there we got is
like that little pupae top thing and and
this one has sorry I'm just trying to
get it out there so that's exactly the
top of little pupae balls and goal
structures that are created by these
little goal wasps and then from there on
they would obviously be coming out so
very characteristic of the sole the
class the leaf and we see that quite a
lot and some of the acacias we can
actually get with a sting the thorns but
that is more down to little ants they
will sting the thorns and in those
acacia well now some of them being
virtue Lea and those thorns will
actually swell up like the branch is
done here on the silver cluster leaf and
in the ends actually having their little
nests on the inside there so obviously
this time of year we try to look for all
these kind of little things but very
much dormant part for the arthropods and
very quiet actually indeed because you
know in summer you can walk
and every single piece of bark or stone
that you pick up there's something there
is something alive and it's really
noticeable at this time of year how
quiet it gets on that front and you can
also feel the pure dryness of the
vegetation as you walking through it now
at the moment as well
now Gary for me the ticks aren't a
problem at all in the wintertime I've
had little to no bites at this
particular time but some of the guards
have said there is the odd one so I
would say that there's a definite
reduction in the amount of ticks that we
do have at this time but they're they're
not completely gone but they very little
around I must say so they're also
probably pretty dormant in the egg phase
now little eggs in the surface of the
soil waiting for that first little bit
of rain like a lot of the other
arthropods and arachnids and waiting for
just that summer or spring months to
come about once more than that swim none
obviously the grounding just comes to
life all over again and it becomes
fascinating with the amount of life that
you actually find all around so looking
for those little animals here and there
but with the ultimate goal of heading
towards where the cheetah we're and
finding those tracks and I wonder how
it's going with Taylor and those cheetah
not so great and we trying to find them
I don't know where they've gotten so I
think I'm pretty sure I had cheetah
tracks on Triple Aim which is one of the
boundary roads some of them look really
old though but I'm confused because the
cheetah haven't sort of been around for
quite some time and come back this way
and then there was some that looked
really fresh so I'm in two minds I'm
just sort of checking some open areas we
just checked sandy patch and I couldn't
see anything I haven't seen any more
tracks I'm just having a look I mean I
could have been wrong there were also
female leopard tracks that look like
they were there from this morning a bit
further down on the road crossing into
using my BD so I don't know who may have
been walking around there which female
and I did see someone had marked them
definitely the fact from this morning so
what I think I might do is now we just
sort of I suppose doing little perimeter
patrol hoping to pick up on some decent
tracks of the cheetah I think we are we
got to go to Sydney's dam which is that
way and then once we get to Sydney's dam
I'm just checking we will just scan that
area have a little look this water there
it's nice and open there's often and
part of this could be food around those
cheats have a clock they do need to feed
I don't know well they could have gone
back west because there are lots of open
areas in there have been enjoying their
time so I'm not really sure ah and well
speaking of Impala being tasty treats it
seems as though Dave just got some
well good luck Taylor and hopefully
you'll find those cheaters the incident
does very well last night with fog and
also this morning's after all the
bishops but tell ya they may have
something here they may want to eat and
look at those beautiful impalas chewing
khat being ruminants because of the heat
of the day
the estate will slow down and this is
one of the advantages of ruminants from
Oh what the Italia they can slow down a
regurgitate it and then keep reaching it
then solid this particular we see here
must be very busy doing that and again
depends on how much they had eaten the
one behind it doesn't look very you know
hungry or like it had enough to eat
it has regurgitate is enough and just
pushed a knot that just swallowed poop
how nice is that was chewy reach you and
then swallow
temperatures are pretty high would say
you can see from the amount of light
they got there is bit warm so just slow
down and start getting a little bit
busier at dusk over an hour to 6 o clock
so all of them will tend to slow down
enjoy some nice shade and just
regurgitate some of them laying down
there and it has been claimed some of
the ruminants could just be laying down
there and they could have sleep half of
the brain could be sleeping and the
other half not another plus for being a
ruminant I like being a non-ruminant
so you able to rest have enough as you
you know reach you your food then rest
here the side of the brain Mitch
very good comment you see they are so
focused and chewing and yes when you
look at them it's just like how I don't
know you've seen kids especially in the
village it come from
anytime Lord visits the first thing the
kids would tell me I would tell them you
know I have so many goodies for you and
I'll tell them you know what and brought
you fruit I brought you bread of brought
to you some cupcakes
I brought you some gum they'll tell me
stop there gum gum chewing gum chewing
gum and you see those kids zero or frogs
just laughing hear those kids chewing
chewing gum you know it's just like this
imbalance
my name is reminds me of the kids in my
village and yes yes so focused algorithm
on you know just reviewing the food
because the bit softer then when they
first you know solid it so it goes
through all the four chambers in their
stomachs so when it comes back it has
gone through a bit of bacteria they've
softened a bit and I think it usually it
is a little different and maybe tastier
so they tend to think they're eating
different food maybe is like how we eat
our main course and then we have a
desert and the desert always tend to be
the best parts of a meal what do you
think [ __ ] yeah Foxy's yes yeah they
shouldn't be allowed to eat until the
veggies are finished and I hope these
impalas have just done that they are
finished their wages and that's how it
now they are enjoying that part and you
might notice they might continue you
know regurgitating and reaching the food
a lot long under the time they'll spend
eating just because I said it's just a
little better
you might hear the plane from the group
from the air flying
haha
Gary how are you and that's a good
question and you asked him do they
always do in one direction and I think
you're giving me some homework towards
this particular one because it's like
going in one direction and I'm thinking
how do I kill my food myself and even
know how I chew
I should know how the impalas chill
what fab you need to do is you show us a
different impala chewin you've got some
work to do and we find out is it chewing
this way can you say this is tuned
anti-clockwise let's see if we get
another one here it's a searching and
clockwise right
it's likes moving the lower mandible to
the left - my thinking does
anti-clockwise maybe two more and then
if that should be the case Gary we can
say they move the lower model yes like
anti-clockwise it seems so and I'm not
sure to say either they're left-handed
or right-handed and that's how they move
you know their mouth and especially in
the lower parts because he's only the
lawn that is moving and the top one
where the no sir
well then the nosies is not moving at
all but that's one of the most
interesting questions I've ever had and
I've never looked carefully and thought
when they chew how do they move their
mouth and we think I think I'll be
looking myself you know in a mirror
tonight when I'll be having dinner maybe
me and fun and you'll find out how it's
your food maybe it's a prickly fog and
then we compare notes
I don't know human beings how we also
eat but if you look at this - the
chewing in the same direction so it's
either left to right or right left and
they're facing the other way is
difficult to know but most important is
the lower part that moves and not the
upper mandible something called the
attention there and as much as they slow
down when needed a room in it they never
want to take any chances
because they know the Predators can take
that advantage and sneak on them very
quickly it will sprout good question do
antelopes have more than one set of
teeth no they only have one set and
that's it and the only animals I think
that might have more than one set of
teeth are the Ellie's the elephant's I
think I guess they got six sets of teeth
but all antelopes I know of once they
lose the teeth and just like we human
beings once we lose our permanent teeth
unless we go and do some dentures or do
some dental work that's it you lose all
your TV I've seen a few animals
especially buffaloes when they age up
and not you're missing so many teeth so
antelope I think we'll always have one
set of teeth and that's it other animals
I must be thinking of all the crocodiles
the crocodiles have been known once they
have their teeth once they turn where we
are able to replace the teeth and have a
new set I do not know how many sets the
end of having but crops will have if one
particular tooth is broken or is worn
out it is replaced by another one
popping up from top bottom but Ellie's
we know before they die they'll have
about six sets of teeth in their life
and the teeth tend to grow backwards
forth and for the antelopes is upwards
downwards and downwards up weren't just
like us human beings remember 12 units
viewers asking questions is all is very
hard for us because what we do here is
very interactive interactive game drive
and you know with your questions and
comments and your feelings you make us
feel alive because we only see you
through the lands and ruff is still
tracking
while we are tracking and we're also
just looking at any of the little Oscar
pods that are active at the moment and
and I just want to do a little check
just to see if this antlion larva over
here and sins are saying wait for him
I'm just want to see with these little
conical put traps obviously that the
little end line lava is waiting at the
bottom for little ant just to walk along
the edge like I'm just pretending here
and I'm not going to destroy his little
conical but I just want to see if he's
actually at home and if he is you'd be
throwing the sand up just to try and
knock there he is
you see that he's knocking the sand up
in an attempt to knock the little ant
down that I'm just pretending to be he's
at the bottom there and sometimes if I'm
talking like this he might actually
realize that I'm here and then he marked
up quiet but let's just see I can see
these little pincers in the bottom of
the pit there they back up again you see
that there we go that's very cool okay I
went to stab him too much but you know
I've said this many times but once again
for any new viewers that's a little lava
of a life swing or the adult and climb
and what he's doing there is he's
sitting there in the bottom waiting for
unsuspecting ants a little insects to
come walking along then they throw that
sand up like that and once that knocks
him down to the bottom that with those
two punches that he's using to throw the
sand he'll grab onto that little insect
and pull it down and those pincers are
actually Hollow and they've got little
needles on the end so they Pierce
whatever it is whether it's an ant or
whatever and then through those hollow
has sort of syringe like pincers
they will then and be and sucking all
the juices out of them and you came in
oh the next one so let's check that one
this one over here we go see that so
then now suck all the juices out and
then just take it a little bit further
down then this one's also a little bit
active and they normally get active when
it gets a bit hot in the middle of the
day as well so you
can see just from the soil around it
that it's actually quite active because
it's been kept nice and clean there's
another smaller one here to see if he's
if he's willing to play along not always
that one just started kicking some sand
up doing some maintenance there again
and you know what it's actually
incredible because in this face they can
actually stay in the lava phase for up
to ten years and that is absolutely
sensational for such a little creature
to live for so long and what happens
then is they obviously metamorphosize
into the adult lice wing and when
they're at that stage they don't have a
mouth they don't have mouth spots so
they can't even eat so what they will do
is there it will defecate once that will
mate and they will die and it can happen
in two to three days so up to ten years
in the larval phase but up to possibly a
maximum of about three days in the adult
and it's all done so once they do get to
that phase the lice wing they're
actually really pretty but it doesn't
last for long so one of those what
interesting little last cycles of that
of the endline now ash obviously I've
been you know moving around and guiding
and being in the wilderness for now
twenty years since I started studying or
since I finished high school so well
it's taken all of that time to be able
to have such a you know well not a
bigger set of experience of all these
different creatures but I still you know
I don't profess to know anything anyway
near all the stuff that's our chair in
the bush and it's nice to find new
things every time you go out and then
trauma identify them and those are the
ones that you always remember the way
you put the most effort into actually
finding out what it is so when it's
something that's out of the ordinary
that's actually the best and easiest way
for you to remember once you eventually
find out what it is and basically the
interesting stuff as well so that's what
we're always looking for when you're
walking you know anything out of the
ordinary anything different that we can
ever look at and debate and maybe
possibly identify as well and and then
we learn as we go along
yeah looks like you know that's just an
old African giant land snail shell I
wanted that would be quite interesting
for a hermit crab to use one of those as
a shell to get quite big in net but
there's also lots of activity of rodents
and I was talking about it a little
while ago because we saw a lot of owl
tracks on the road and these are the
type of little holes that these photoed
elephant shrews and little gerbils and
mice and even rats that will use these
little tunnels and they actually get
quite a little highway as well moving
through the grass which they make
fantastic pathways through yeah and
obviously run up and down through them
now speaking of pathways and highways
let's go on over to Dave I think he's
driving around
because lipids will also eat Lawrence
and Toki of lipids and rodents I'm
talking over sim but they're hunting
turn a photon oh sorry it up he's gone
don't worry there's a rebel hornbill
there and we are cooking or cooking over
the lipids and my plans today are to see
a vote see any little pot and not any
with a choice between Tandy and tin gana
out Prefontaine Ghana being a man so
that I can tell him happy Father's Day
so I'm sure he has fathered a number of
cups around this area I don't know how
many Cubs he has for that he has done
pretty job and hopefully he will
continue for three you know getting more
cups he's about 12 years old he's a
leopard around this area so r12 he has
done very well I'll be more than happy
if you could see a few more cabs from
him so that's my main plan today
hopefully I don't this is my signal at
this point this is one area last Andy
loves to come we saw here the other day
with a kill what you have today is an
Jana let's see if then I will study
because because your is a mail and fog
let me know at what point you are [ __ ]
okay are you just talking yell I thank
you for looking at me because I want to
tell you happy Father's Day
sorry father and that's a big bull yalla
and I'm sure he's aware today's Father's
Day and feeding on his own and again
just like the crudity so before these
browsers and you can tell that's maybe
the highest he can eat in terms of
reaching on the top leaves as a browser
but it could as we saw earlier had much
longer necks and they'll go further
looking or getting leaves that are full
of moisture and maybe much younger
leaves or tweaks from the trees turns
around so to make a move charge Nora
you're asking whether we have any okapis
located in this region not clearly touch
nor okapis I'm sure you know they look
like half giraffe have zebra the nearest
one out see from here be like ah some
thousands of mile away in a country
called DRC Congo or Democratic Republic
of Congo in zell Least Concern before
that's where you could see okapis not
very many left but not any that I know
in this region of South Africa or in
East Africa the only place out maybe
guarantee if you're lucky to see them
would be the DRC that's where you'd see
no copies and they have been in a red
listed by the IUCN now because you know
they have been poached a lot because of
the beautiful skin and the IUCN have you
know red listed them and hopefully we're
looking at the numbers growing and
getting big in future and for people to
be able to see them not sure if they
would survive here cuz they tend to stay
in more thickets big forests high ground
and that you will have lots of rain and
possibly all around the and maybe not
survive like the Nala we got here the
only commonality I would say between the
two are the stripes you see here but
these stripes are much thinner on these
nila balls at UT in Anoka P so when they
don't list the top leaves they've been
digging some roots or some small forms
of plants from the ground and being
browsers they will not be grazing at all
seldom you see them you know grazing by
sequest criteria they'll always be
browsing but now odd considering there
is to dig some rhizomes or any roots
from the grass
and then moving closer to that shaded
area where a chief can eat and give
tonight shady girl spider you asking me
whether I have seen an elegance or
dominance you know play by the two boots
I have not and that's one thing I'm
really looking forward to see I've
always seen it on documentaries but of
course when my colleagues have been out
on green grass on Safari like I've seen
them do it I've seen you know James
Henry Taylor Christian you know all of
them and rough personally I have not
seen but I'd be more than happy to see a
display of Mel because I think it is
something very exciting when I'm saying
that I would want also to imitate it as
they'll do it how they make themselves
begin turning around but more seeing
more of the fight than the display of
dominance if I'd be lucky to see three
for them together that would be exciting
and see maybe we can read them and do a
poll on who will do better than the
other can see the tip you know on end of
the horns like every and as they get
bigger it always shows a bit of maturity
and to see him alone there shows how
mature how he you know how and all he is
fantastic looking very clean Yala is
someone who doesn't want to look very
clean now everyone I'm just looking at a
little bit of a crime scene here because
seems to be a little birdie that has
been eaten just well he's definitely
being plucked just at the at the
entrance to a to an art for Poirot as
well and I'm not sure what else would
have been using it there but you can see
all of these feathers yeah lots of white
dots well what was brown dots now why
don't we see what do you guys think what
bird was this let's lay out them I'm
just gonna put a chest in there because
I
to get out some of the other ones as
well these are the characteristic colors
that we've got here there's another one
so something with brown and black sort
of stripes like that but also this looks
like the baby part or the down feathers
and softer areas and they sort of got a
white with the black stripe on it very
fluffy here this probably mostly due to
the from the chest area of the bird and
you see they all these colors so why
don't you guys send through what do you
think what bird is this anybody no it's
good the answers in there and see what
you guys think and then we can also see
what do you think ate it I'm gonna start
just to speak what I think might've
eaten it yeah I think this it couldn't
be a Mongoose something like a little
Mongoose it would obviously have been
eaten on the ground here and I'm
wondering if the stick was used as a
perch site or if it was just sort of
attacked into this little corner here
and this is where it started to pluck
the feathers I don't see any fresh
tracks of anything around here
you know slimmed among this would be an
ideal kind of candidate but then we
could also have any of the the bird
eating Raptors as well even down to the
little pill spotted outlets they also
kill little birds and eat them the
sparrowhawks the African goshawk what
else could be even a little jackal now
Christina I don't think that's a crystal
bar but no because a crystal bobberts
got lots of yellow and green and very
almost luminous colors when you see this
is very indicative light brown with
black and then a little bit of what with
dark brown to black that's all in the
greater part of these feathers here see
that this quite indicative colors yeah
made yeah it is a bird that is clearly
missing some feathers I would say I
think that's probably the least of this
little birds problems because I'm pretty
sure it's already been digested by
whatever ingested it there's lots of
feathers around oh that's quite a pretty
one there cuz cider um I suppose it
could have been a Franklin I would
probably think one of the smaller ones
like a Koki Franklin that's that is an
option of Koki Franklin is it oh he has
another last color there now the last
big feather there it is see see these
these colors these colors are very
characteristic here pretty sure you know
I don't know that the exact answer I'm
just also gonna you know think maybe
maybe a little quail maybe a little
button quail these feathers are rather
small so and these look like these are
possibly wing feathers or tail feathers
those ones there so it's a small little
bit whatever it is I would say a little
button quail or like you say maybe a
Koki Franklin they are quite small as
well the other ones that possibly could
also be is maybe something like a night
jar and but you guys with your screen
shots and so on you might be able to
take a little picture of those feathers
so maybe you'd be able to match them up
with a different bird or two I'm not
exactly sure but it's one of these sort
of brownie black colored builds a small
little beard as well and I would think
that it's some kind of nocturnal bird or
Raptor that's actually nailed it C as
well Simon yeah you could be right as
well maybe it was a bar a grass owl that
any of the little owls that fly around
here at night as well and I'm sure that
they could have got himself a little
quail or the one of the night jaws etc
but there's a lot of feathers as I say
and very characteristic colors they
anyway that's a mystery for now let's
see what information you guys can come
up with otherwise I'll have a look also
when I get back to camp in my bird book
and just those exact colors there it's
quite characteristic so you know that's
very interesting and as I say stop being
along the way for anything interesting
like that we are still making our way
towards where those cheetah were last
seen this morning but um these little
things always interest me and be a crime
scene or something that we don't know
exactly what has happened and we try and
work out the mystery that see the search
for the cheetah seems to be continuing
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
now likely crank is quick on his hands
there goodness we've got one on Sean but
he's got to walk on frame in a second or
maybe he'll just stand there very nicely
for us hello well that's of course an
injury well snapped horn from fighting
with the other Impala
I don't know Anna do you did that though
it's kind of hard to see doesn't doesn't
look new maybe three difficult to tell
that's not giving him a little bit of a
headache but I've never seen an Impala
die from a chopped off horn know you're
really dangerous hey no next year
goodness gracious he's gonna be a really
really good contender well I have one on
Sean
like a knife like a sword now okay so
the cheetah have I think they've crossed
waist I think they've moved off of the
property because I had some tracks and
then I was going back to go and look at
them again and an unfortunately a
ginormous truck drove straight overhaul
of the tracks that I'd mark nothing
and then another car just in case the
truck didn't get them came the opposite
way and since Craig and I have gone up
and down there we've just been seeing
cars and it's a boundary road of course
and one of the roads at all the delivery
vehicles and things use so it's normal
you don't normally get to see many
tracks there and then she can beat the
the traffic in the early morning so now
I think we shall not look for cats we're
gonna for everything else and there may
be some cats will appear I would like to
see wild dog at some point that could be
quite cool maybe they'll be around but
I'm still just checking just checking
around here maybe we missed those
cheetah maybe they walks on the Triple M
and then came back this way because they
were coming north and then they've
changed their direction and gotten west
in very interesting so maybe some draw
maybe some elephants maybe some zebra
wildebeest will be quite nice probably
try to do a little bit of birding if we
see a decent bird party I think that's
what we've got sort of planned and then
I'm looking forward to this evening so
some nocturnal critters at least young
it does get quite chilly it's um it's
not too bad last night wasn't the
coldest but we have had a couple of sort
of chilly days now that these cards have
disappeared maybe we'll we'll get some
more chilly evenings it kind of it kind
of dropped from about 18 degrees just as
the Sun Goes Down and this is the Greece
Celsius of course and then warming by
the time we've woken up in the morning
it's anywhere between about 8 and 12
degrees somewhere around there though
this morning must have been about 15 or
16 degrees Celsius so that's not what's
cold it's once you start driving that it
becomes really really chilly because
there is a little bit of a nip in the
air at the moment but bit of frost not
that there's actual frost or anything
down on it on the ground or any of the
vegetation but it does
it does make you quite cold there's some
Franklin's that are making noises yet
let's see what they're making noises
about why you lying try and see we won't
get it we're not gonna get a keen B we
gonna get an abstracted B I'm afraid
there's a family of them the towles
profiles and little ones and you see the
chicks running through ya
so that's one there's so many of them
he's sunk I saw about three or four just
running off young young chicks maybe
that's what they're talking about many
are getting a little bit too far they're
all up on this up on the tree that was
just to the right of us just sitting up
there
I don't think it was necessarily
anything now there was chatter at
breakfast today about Sam solving the
mystery of where Scuba Steve has gone
and I think David is a really solved it
yes Taylor you should not panic as we
all worried when we missed our goslings
and now Scuba Steve has not only
resurfaced from the water but he has
resurfaced to his your home trees usual
position we just came here because for
two or three days he has been missing in
action and the last person to be here
well he also went under but after a few
minutes or a few seconds he gonna
resurface again which is very typical of
hippos and the last person here was
Steve and Steve came back to the camp
and told us he is a bit worried that
Scuba Steve has gone missing
and we thought did he go to Russia
towards some football
maybe not if you did he was the African
teams were not doing very well and this
morning he caught a direct flight back
to South Africa
and we have always debated how long will
he post a under the water before breath
you think that was just slightly under
one minute Scuba Steve did you breathe
would you just come out to look and
we'll always tell when they breathe
sometimes they just blow water out of
the noses and look at him just keeping
an eye on us how are you doing where had
you gone scuba Steve I'm trying to mind
in the dearest what holes from here
because hippos cannot stay out of water
for more than five hours especially
during the day out unless they stay
under some very you know good figures or
they'll have good cover and protecting
the very sensitive skin from the Sun I
would just wonder where he had gone
honnestly and think of cheetah waterhole
I do not think so that is one area that
he's occupied good job your [ __ ] you can
get him he's sleepy or do you think he
won't have enough
so what still the eyes are aimed but the
ears are out so he has a choice of
listening to us without looking at us
and then he goes let me go down and
thank you very much
and Louie the final control things he
likes the sound of my voice thank you
maybe hopefully it was the case file and
Scuba Steve just know we are here to see
the turnip it's on the other end of the
hall if go Nina we had been watching
some Tara prints there that have been
sunning themselves teeny bit of
sunbathing and once this sense of you
think something could go wrong
they'll very quickly go back to the
water
fantastic good news we got a scuba yeah
there he is again one more look at him
let go pictures who asked him what
happened to those Gosling's and the
geese and I think we might be going to
the third week now if I'm not wrong and
nobody knows for a fact what transpired
we have had so many theories but
personally my guess is they relocated to
another town I mean you know they
relocated to another waterhole because
they're just too young to be on their
own and you know until maybe the curry
about six eight months for them to start
living separately I just think they went
to a different waterhole and we also had
a fury of predation and maybe resort
some egos or some leopards could have
gotten them but it's not easy to lose
seven Gosling's together plus their
parents so we just think personally I
think they just went to another area and
hopefully we shall know where they are
also be seen at one point very good some
blacksmiths lapwings there well done son
so blacksmiths slapping laughing so you
see them they're very aquatic but
sometimes they are so terrestrial you
will see them closed water and sometimes
away from water and like most lapwings
they'll keep looking for food for
anything
aquatic on the water surface or on the
edge of the water and occasionally
they'll be roosting who having nests not
far from such an area very monogamous
lop wings
actually that's a very good question why
is he on his own Winnipeg Scuba Steve
and we have always been wondering why
has he been living alone but I see
hippos are very dominant and in the
hierarchy if he has not been able to
establish you know some females of
himself he ends up being you know living
alone but the question has been when he
leaves this particular waterhole where
does he go because we have not spotted
him in any other waterhole for us either
his smallish or he's not strong enough
to establish his own territory and have
some ladies with himself
that's my only guess or he could be
having some health issues that we do not
know and he has been enjoying this place
maybe hoping one day some ladies will
come around which throw the difficult
because the males who the ladies we
always skip the famous Scuba Steve as
you breathe blowing air out there we
would wonder and ask you why do you live
alone occasionally we have seen two
other males I mean to the hippos here
not sure there are females or males but
totalling to three and then the two ten
twenty sepia and Scuba Steve has always
remained alone but that should be a very
important question to know why he has
always remained alone and when he leaves
the water where does he normally go but
a good Scuba Steve will let you enjoy
you afternoon and please viewers
remember your questions are always very
welcome on hashtag safari life keep
treating us anything you want to know
about the hippo as you see him blowing
some air there opening the eye and
closing and this is one of the animals
we don't take chances with in Africa any
time you meet a hippo out of the water
he should consider taking any measure to
take care of yourself otherwise they
have been known to kill so many people
in Africa together the buffalos but like
the villager come from we have seen more
damage and deaths caused by hippos
the trucking team continues doing a good
job well and it seems like there's a few
people that think that that crime scene
or that little birdie that had been
plucked and probably eaten you guys
think maybe an African loopy that's not
a bad choice I wonder if those feathers
will fit the exact pattern of of an
African hippie on it seems similar
colors but I don't think that they the
quack pattern would match but I stand
corrected
anyway um I'll just stop next to read
bush wallah obviously because these are
one of the plants that are seeding at
the moment and fruiting and you can see
very nicely that's the red bush will
I'll compete in a pickle autumn and
always with cambree tum' you have these
4 winged seed pods like that and very
indicative of a cambria more bush well
we've just walked past another one which
has got very similar sees seeds very
similar size as well but just a slightly
different color to them that's a russet
bush Willa and you can see why they call
it russet because it almost looks
exactly like rust that's how I always
remembered it on a russet also the color
but slightly different in there in the
size of the tree and the leaves but
almost identical and they seed pods and
obviously they both fruiting not at the
moment and does make for beautiful
colors out here in the bush at the
moment - now they're not the only one
that are seeding we've got lots of the
grass that are seeding as well and this
one in particular is one of my favorite
crosses the blue seed grass if you have
a look nice and closely they it's just
blowing in the wind of it you can see
what I call it blue seed grass but
that's not blue tinge on the end of the
seeds and or one of the nicer ones that
are seeding at the moment but seems to
be coming to an end with the grasses the
seeding process I mean and as we head
into full winter and then into spring
obviously that whole cycles gonna start
repeating itself now we seem to have got
information from Tyler that the cheetah
search is possibly over because there
might have crossed to the west we're
gonna go and confirm that and just see
if we don't pick up some fresh tracks
moving back onto the property who knows
they might have gone out but they could
really be back on or maybe they didn't
go I better art in the first place we
just want to confirm that and if we can
then then we'll try and find them
alternatively we'll just keep on walking
nice and slowly and seeing whatever we
can find along these nice well-worn game
paths because there's always something
to be found looking under all the little
logs and so on where we might find some
scorpions or anything just riding up now
Zach these these bush villas they major
protection I would say is in the
hardness of the wood you won't
particularly find elephants in that
breaking of entire branches and big ones
anyway they do take the smaller ones and
what elephants will eat on a bush wala
bronze it's just literally the bark so
they do roll these around in their
mouths and and and sort of feeding on
this bark but then the rest of the wood
is very very hard so it's pretty well
protected against wood Boras and and
termites etc is the red bush willow one
of the best fire woods around and the
rest of the bush Willa is also a very
nice hardwood but the animals do browse
on its a little bit and I suppose it's
just down to a little bit of chemical
warfare with some of the animals some
but they do make the leaves a little bit
more bitter if they've been fed on quite
a lot as do a lot of the the trees and
that as soon as they start getting fade
on a little bit they do then pump some
chemicals into the leaves making them
better so as I say just walking along on
this beautiful winter's afternoon see
and stopping for whatever we can find
and we're just gonna continue on doing
that wonderful wonderful I hope you
enjoy it
so I got really excited I was like oh
cheetah tracks and then had forgotten
what road I was on earth or maybe
they've made a return but it isn't it's
ones when they walk from the repeater to
Zoe's Road so there's eight tracks
there's a couple going around here but I
think I think this was still from
earlier this morning when they were
moving around a little bit hmm let's go
that way
sorry I'm changing my mind a very very
indecisive today which is a problem when
you're on a safari decisiveness is
oopsie is not great weight over the
bumps yeah thus you were walking up and
down but I don't know anything these are
as fresh as the ones that I had seen a
little while ago and so yeah and taxon
is also convinced Texel is a guide from
Juma that they have cross waist if
you'll just keep checking go back down
all the way and
just check sort of towards triage down
like I said if we get to some elephants
and things along the way
that would be really really quite nice
we might have to go and try and find
that herd of elephants that we were with
this morning but and we're feeding in a
drainage line but knowing how quickly
elephants commute to they could have
also crossed to the east that could have
gone towards torturing so from here
we'll slowly start making our way that
side and then maybe a little bit later
we will pop into chitra I'm trying to
get an update from that side to see if
there's anything happening so yeah so
that's sort of our plan but it's quiet
again again the cat surveyed me they
just let me see them on foot and then in
the car not allowed to see them in the
vehicle apparently wonderful okay maybe
we want to do a bit of birding too this
is much out this afternoon which I'm
surprised by because it is such a
beautiful afternoon as well sort of
pointed out it's it's really stunning
it's not too hot
was hot at one point and then the clouds
came over and now it's actually the
perfect temperature to have a jacket on
well jersey on Craig's got his big
jacket on already but I think it's gonna
turn into a chilly night squirrel
why did you run in front of my car like
that
he's just they may jumps you thief he's
gonna come out he should see the ride
squirrel squirrel squirrel squirrel
squirrel I don't know how you at corner
squirrel gg gg gg gg gg gg
and of course jeez don't call the
animals especially a cheetah or
something I think it's one thing as
playing around other little animals I
just look about something go no and then
they run away anyways look well it was a
squirrel but my favorite my favorite
thing in the whole wide world and I
think it's every-every guards pitch
haters when people call the animals when
they go to a lion what you're gonna do
measure that lion goes hmm
okay so excited you know like get up and
I run to the Congo yes or there's
another one I promise you I have tried
because obviously I need to test the
theory I've tried to make every Sun next
to a lion next to a leopard once in my
life it doesn't work it doesn't get them
to look at you and s it's an
exceptionally skittish animal but why
would you even really want to be
tormenting a very nervous and we want to
be quiet and trying to get them used to
the vehicles initially you don't start
off with strange sounds when you have
virtuix animals I mean even turn the
radios down that to a point and then
introduce loud blaring radios that can
be experienced you know when you're in
sightings with other safari guides so
I've tried it it doesn't work so there's
no need to do it I'm doing this what all
the Safari got ads out there they'll
thank me later but it is really really
funny because I mean I suppose
especially when you're looking at a lion
or something I think you just look like
cats and of course why wouldn't you want
to try and call the animals but they
don't know they haven't been trained so
they don't even know what you're trying
to do to them or what what the purpose
is of making those sounds
I probably think humans are weird Craig
and I were chatting just now we wondered
if animals log human sightings like I
wonder if the cheetah ate off we had
another encounter with people we thought
it was gonna be quite dangerous but it
turned out ok I wonder if they do that
as well
now I'm taking all said and we have to
lock all what I walk swish you really
should be yeah exactly I was saying now
is directing just wait do you think they
ever get excited and go ooh human with
blond hair that's a reciting you know
things like that you know I wonder
one day I'll ask all the animals these
questions when I get super powers to
talk to them I think I need to get
bitten by what a new killer spider a
nuclear active a radioactive spider
sorry um something like that but I don't
want to be shooting webs I don't want to
be doing that well that could be quite
fun I can't imagine would be very useful
for my job but if I could speak to the
animals hey that would be amazing
I may even choose speaking to the
animals overflying if I was given those
two things okay so no like yeah um I
think those those tracks that I had seen
was was from earlier today they were
just wandering around but anyways we're
playing a very tough game of ways Wadley
out here in the bush trying to find the
animals and well David seems to be
playing that game too
yes super job to do and the whole idea
is keep looking keep looking until luck
strikes we have done pretty well out
there since we started and I've covered
about 10% of the area I was thinking to
look for in Ghana so I still got another
90 percent to go around looking around
but in the meantime I'm thinking if I
don't get in Ghana to wish him happy
birthday then I can concentrate on Tandy
and beautiful princess and this is one
particular area that they love hanging
out because it's not very far from where
she was born so I want to spend some
couple of minutes here looking around so
yeah you're right [ __ ] it just straight
on a stick in a box and just gets into
fogs way or his camera but he survived
yeah I mean the lumber was born around
this area so it's not an issue for the
mother to keep coming to the same area
whereas she gave birth to and we have
seen China here couple of times seems
some female Yala's here I do not know
what [ __ ] you think whether you're gonna
move forward or just stop there move
forward all right seen lots of similar
one was today from the wildebeest to the
Kudus we saw earlier but now he gosh
bananas it's always beautiful to see
them getting the leaves or the bush
willows before the old dry up or before
they leave the shut it down and she's
such a heart and two of them are having
a little go for each other I'm not sure
why the practice but it's very typical
for males you know I like the females
which do not normally fight once the
whole it's very neutral I don't know the
last time I saw two females fighting of
any species but males like that young
one they're most likely does more of a
play fight than an actual fight just too
young to be fighting and I'm sure the
mother
put a bit of discipline hold on to them
this should not happen you're too young
but if you play fighting that's okay
the thing you need to do is to keep
eating as the wind is picking up slowly
you can see from the grass how it's
moving their severity because it's our
round we have seen wind picking up
absolutely I will do that I mean our
just stop we will move forward
okay that's good fun okay my foot of the
brick sir Ebola excellent cannulas also
just like the kudu so our browsers I'll
just crush they're trying to imagine me
needing some oxpeckers if they have any
ticks with them they'll stop to it if
the wind picks up very much which does
it all go very well with most of the
antelopes because the sense of hearing
is a bit imbalanced still very each or
something there
very good welcome and that's a good
question and you're asking what does the
one yella mean and I think from the
local people here I think this youngin
yella means onion and I'll confirm but I
will loo in the front of control chrome
that declares Liu thank you very much
that was just a guess I think I was
taught that you know some months ago and
yeah I mean yalla actually means onion
and what an interesting name or do you
want to know high onion you know or do
they look like onions or they smell like
onions we have found animals for example
the waterboxx
having a particular smell very good
and loo from from the control tower is
because the tentorium of the layers on
onions and our groceries and even look
at them carefully from the straps they
got yes they're just like you know the
layers especially when you peel the
onion that we dig from the ground
thank you very much true I do not know
how the mists of the knee allowed whoops
something must have scope him there if
any of one of them steps on a real stick
and two breaks it and if they're not
sure what might have happened they'll
always take off just thinking with
someone who is after them and that's why
they'll stop fast from eating and fast
concentrate and find out what could be
happening and either change direction
immediately but all looks good so you
got youngster Zi yang stuff emails and
youngster mails not a big moves like
what we saw earlier and you can see how
the bush willows are being moved by the
air as the wind is picking up
fantastic
very good Neela's keep enjoying yourself
hopefully all will be safe as we move
forward all right
a beautiful girl is still searching
every time David says that so we've seen
so far since you last saw so you've seen
one blacksmith Lapwing Hey how exciting
is that we decided to move on from the
blacksmith lettering though because we
want to find something more amazing even
though there are really cool birds we've
just we've been spending lots of time
with him and maybe we'll find someone on
a gonner you see it up top there let's
see where are you I think it's a little
bit higher it's there ah there we go
it was a tricky one to see though hello
that's so cool these creatures are blue
headed a Ghana also haven't seen one in
ages like for a really really really
long time I enjoyed seeing the agamas
coming down the main road in the Mara
and was a bright red heads and purple
bodies those were those were very
special to sort of see the tree similar
in sort of size and we do see these of
course the tree are gone they're
spending a lot of time on the please and
that's the perfect spot basking in the
Sun catching the last of the golden
glow' and what a perfect house that it
has got there because it's a it's an
oblong tree and one that's not alive
anymore courtesy of the elephants as
they were embarked it but I also think
that the termites have had something to
do with it I bet that they've started
hollowing it out which has now created
the most amazing sort of cavities and
also the bark is quite thick and is
peeling away but hasn't quite sort of
disappeared notice we had fallen off so
look at that perfect hidey hole
that's awesome very nice to see and that
would of course provide a lot of
protection and from Raptors and things
like that but something like a Jim know
gene and African hawk eagle would
specialize in catching all sorts of
critters living in between bark like
that so it's not safe from everybody
also other snakes I mean they could be
preyed on by a variety of different
snakes our chair too but that was nice
that is quite cool to see you know mr.
Craig please remind me we could be just
turning on two Weaver's nice now is that
we must check our tree for the bush
babies we I think that they're living
remember we had them in the top of the
log who are not so we must come and
check that same oh I thought I was gonna
make it today this morning without
sneezing on Safari goodness excuse me
whew almost as she hit my face on the
steering wheel it was the big sneeze
which tree was it now I think it was a
little bit so around the corner it
wasn't as close as I thought to that
Junction I remember thinking okay wasn't
any of these little trees I think it was
this one coming up boo to the left
enjoy yes I would imagine they'd be in
the same family via gama's they'd all
just be whilst both slightly slightly
different but yes that's some somewhere
or another they'll be related they're
the same species I don't think that
there are subspecies there's two
different Craig things you're not the is
though there's a squirt oh it's a
pecking as I pointed that there was a
squirrel watching us from that hole that
you've got in there and the screen it
just had its head out it was quite
creepy actually the way it was just
spying on us if you you you know can you
see that big hole I think I could still
see it a little bit I thought I saw its
tail now and Pradeep the squirrel man is
actually watching so maybe it'll poke
its head out again I think I may have
given a fright that I pointed really
quickly because I got so excited there
was something in the tree maybe we're
gonna do today we're just gonna look
inside the trees for all sorts of things
now shine squirrel very very shy
squirrel anyways there's one of these
trees around here yeah where where the
bush babies were living so we'll come in
and have a look and check around here
again but that's of course we'll have to
be a little bit late to this evening
it's still never too early or the or the
bush babies to come out and actually
come out at night in case you don't know
what what we're talking about and why
they aren't around
okie-dokie right perfect timing because
we're just about to a jump on to gar
remain where the road gets a little bit
bumpy so we got a rough
well everyone as per usual I'm out on
bush walk and you know that I do like to
get up close and personal with the
different kinds of dung around and so I
want to ask of you
to tell me these three different tongues
here they look almost exactly the same
but just of varying sizes now that first
one over there very very small tiny
little down pilots getting a little bit
bigger over here and ultimately a little
bit more sizable over there
so who flung this dung and I want to
just try and show you a little bit
relativity wise how big it is and
there's a quite hard little dung pilots
now remember when these animals
obviously do exhibit these little dung
pellets it's some ruminants so you
wouldn't have a han gut 4 min temp and
this one live very very hard little dung
pilots as well so I'm actually needing
to use my little pair of pliers to break
it up very fine so obviously from a
small little ant alight I want to know
which one you might think that is so and
I can't really see the particles on the
inside there so that's quite interesting
Larry you say let's get the scoop on the
poop absolutely so we had that tiny
little one and with those little ones
and there's a couple of different
animals that you're probably going to be
leaning towards and actually one of them
berries they don't so just give you an
idea of where this one was found this
was not buried and it was found a little
bit in the thickets okay so the next
size up that one a little bit bigger and
this one is a little bit fresher as well
but very very similar on the inside
looks like a little bit of a mixture
maybe some leaves and grass in me not
exactly sure it's very very small and
it's been very well chewed now this was
found a little bit out in the open
but near to some thickets so that gives
you an idea of this kind of habitat and
it was also in a very big midden so
there was lots of dang around and lots
of different individuals you could see
we were using a common latrine site now
this last one little bit bigger but this
found completely on its own and well as
I say little bit bigger and I'll
probably find that there'll be bigger
parts in there as well there looks like
a little bit of grass stalks a little
bit of fragments of leaves as well and
so we've got now three different sized
dung pellets but this is you know all
part and parcel to tracking because it's
one of the check and signs not
necessarily always just going to find
tracks of animals you can also just find
signs of them so poo obviously being a
major sign of an animal that moves
through an area and maybe also where
they've been frequenting and who are
they territorial or not etc now Zac you
say Impala kudu and giraffe Zac I would
say that two of those are correct
however the numbering is wrong because
the numbering is wrong on that because
you've got to write in parlor and kudu
but the numbering wrong so let's see
what other ones you guys say I'm not
going to tell you exactly which one but
yes as I say these are rather small
medium-sized there and then a little bit
more like rugby ball sized on shape okay
Justin you also got another two right
but you say scrub here and what does
that stem buck and I think Impala
so you've got one slash maybe two out of
those so but that's great guys thanks a
lot for the attempt this
here now what would it be Steinbach or
dykey one of them does bury they down
okay and which one is that Herbie which
one berries is done Sternbach berries
it's done so very easy this one was not
buried so it's gonna be our little
common duiker that would have made those
little ones they're the Impala
on a nice big mutton absolutely that's
ours there and then this over here
number three would be that from either
niala or kudu her B&R couldn't decide
between the two of them they are very
similar are there between Nala and kuru
but if I had to bet on it I would
probably go with niala because I think
kudu are slightly more cylindrical than
these are almost boxy top shape anyway
that's the one listen for us who flung
down this afternoon so thanks for
joining on that part of the afternoon
bush walk we will be looking now if we
can find any more signs of these
beautiful cheetah cats we're just going
to check we now up our sandy patch we're
gonna head towards Sidney's and we're
gonna go and see hopefully these cats
have returned
good luck ruff and hopefully you see
those cheaters for us and he's always
amazing to see those two cubs playing
and full of energy
like no last night and more so this
morning they give us a very very good
show
no not yet with either ting Ghana Oh
Tandy or any other little pod not even
one single truck but that doesn't mean
we are not doing well what you've been
seeing more Ellis trucks and we don't
know what is Eleazar you should be
following them and this is the one
moment you say anything
that's the bush will throat you it's
more than welcome and so when you don't
think about one particular thing things
just just showing up just wanna back up
a little bit so you can see some gory
but I don't know [ __ ] is too high it's
too high let me know and we can move on
it's just good point he's feeding on
some seats there and that's the great
gory but very good job [ __ ] the beam in
learn to feed on seeds volatile leaves
she's not getting some [ __ ] from that
particular tree you don't what type of
tree that hasn't tried Andrew that's
this leaves are dried up picking or some
seeds there hello didn't you know we're
here [ __ ] does a very good job
thank you and I just commenting off good
job oops
but [ __ ] that's all didn't go very far
what could it be feeding on the unless
you're feeding on Thomas or anything
that could be there that new alright
good job that was good entertainment
from the egoriy but one of the best
things i've loved from this quarry but
it's just here the occult
okay you just went just as he [ __ ] very
good job
just try and I know you're a flyweight
okay but either way I still want to play
his code because it's one of the cause
that I love and let's see how that car
will come out I don't know who's being
named in the cam knowledge all right
thank you going but and even budding
this is something interesting all righty
[ __ ] would you like a name or not yet
all right you you give me three choices
of three on words that you love most and
then go to choose the name for you okay
my team player a [ __ ]
give me three and then the viewers he'll
vote I'm sure all of them know you or
the viewers to you say that again wild
dog yes
all right you us now all of yahushua a
you know [ __ ] and he does some great
camera lock and i've asked him to give
me three choices of animals oh you know
any any animal the three that you'd want
to keep a name for and he said honey
badger wild dogs or a baboon and the
bull we got two types of a bones
we got the oliver boon and we got the
yellow baboon which were born are you
talking about fog okay he says only the
moon and fall of you because you know
fog so you want as at one point
hashtag safari life and choose all those
three names what name do we give [ __ ] i
have my name in my heart so between
world herbs and the honey badgers oh no
leave baboon so tweet to us hashtags of
our life and from today we are going to
officially give [ __ ] a new name [ __ ]
alex ikonn [ __ ] Alex aka and I'll be
waiting alrighty
okay
it's now time to look for the kitty cats
term either to call them by name for
them to come out we'll be singing at all
the water points that we know where they
might come for a drink or they might be
hanging around they are waiting for some
prey to come for drink and let's find
out what feelings
Taylor is looking for I refuse none no
cats servile caracal African Wildcat
that's what we're gonna be looking for
but none of the big cats they are
annoying me because they just don't want
me to see them anyways I've got an
update on the cheetah they've been found
there on the massive open area which in
simmer media which I assume is in front
of the lodge but at least quite close by
into the lodge so that's very nice they
go there there so that's good at least
we know where they move so they've yeah
they've been up and doing their thing
today so that's quite cool hopefully
they'll be back soon I like it when they
hang around Jim I'm happy if they just
do the west of us because at least you
know they're close by and the
possibility of a sighting is it's sort
of fairly good I'm gonna try and find my
they might not know about my elephants
and to try and find the elephants that's
I was looking at this morning so I've
just jumped on to drakensberg South I
don't actually know why I came up here
because I wanted to get you in Jana Road
north I don't know why I didn't go along
central ah you know what that's fine we
can just take battle here right this
will be perfect this suits us just fine
I'll check yeah I don't think where they
would have gone to you I haven't seen
any elephant tracks crossing out on GT
cutline haven't seen any tracks crossing
out on Gauri Cutler and dari main sorry
sort of a round two and Dan's area
that's why I thought that they were
gonna hit you but nothing that's odd yet
so maybe around Mumba maybe around we
are sort of that said i think i think
mumble edward so we've got check there
runs chatting on the radio sounds like
it's a quiet drive for everybody it got
as a [ __ ] you've just joined on now
because a little while ago they had an
entire conversation about this it often
comes up but the best superpower that a
God could have is talking to animals and
I'd like to see admits this sauce David
it's a scrub as well let's see what what
they think would it be to be able to
talk to animals in my opinion I think
that's gonna be easy because then I
could just ask everybody when you know
see a giraffe I can say hey buddy how's
it going you know where's where's the
leopards have you seen any today and
then he'll tell me well just know
straight away oh I'll just sit and
listening to animals as they're having
conversations you imagine like these
birds and squirrels and things all
talked about so I think that's gonna be
the most useful but I'm sure super like
super sensitive eyesight would be
amazing to to be able to see in the dark
that'd be great so really good hearing
and so all the all these things would be
amazing yes this is what we're looking
for
poop from the elephant right which way
did they go we're just trying to see
it's very hard here so it's hard to see
where the toenail is which is normally
what you look for in an elephant track
to tell you which way it's going Craig
can you see on your side it's a bit
sandy that way we need to turn around
we've made a mistake
oh here's a question from Louise okay
we're just trading around because the
elephant tracks actually go that way
and now Louise's asked me if I could
speak to the animals would they speak in
accents I'm sure obviously can you
imagine
especially our my best would be to talk
show European Rolla what accent would a
European Road I have all my goodness it
could have all sorts of different types
of things that would be quite cool so
yeah from France I called you accents
very well Craig can there Craig is a
secret hidden talent that gionee shows
us every now and then and that's you can
do accents really well Craig please can
you do please just one just the European
you can just pretend you're Sebastian
because you do a good Sebastian
impersonation so what would a European
role is say and how would it sound yeah
that's everyone puts me on the spot all
the time just one night okay Craig you
have to say ah the caterpillars here in
South Africa are much tastier than the
ones in France I don't know but that's
not where Sebastian from he's from Gabon
but he has a French accent so it will
get Bernie's ex interview oh come on
it's good go Craig and now you can
come on Craig come on Craig that's
something we say old itself let's show
you that's what lose just ain't enough
you're not gonna do it
I can't to you exhales I really
unfortunately you've seen Craig has
denied the challenge I should have
pulled out the train card but I think I
left it in my other jacket but Sam yeah
no I I can't
unfortunately contact sense I think we
tried meant to YouTube do a YouTube
tutorial on how to speak like an
Australian that was funny David and I
did that one day a little while ago and
who remembers that drive it was one
evening which is it for ages anybody
last hour of the show it with an
Australian accent may have been on a
straight was I think it may have been
Australia day so that was funny so last
year when is Australia Day in January
forgotten something saying the 14th of
January but I could just be making that
day up I actually don't know when
Australia Day is the 24th it does have a
four in a third okay we're gonna try and
convince Craig to do a European roller
French accent for us let's see if David
could do any accents of the different
animals well unmarked since I'm not sure
what Taylor's talking about
but yes we'll always get my own we had
this impalas here which like a bachelor
club or males young and old it's a
pretty fully grown one you can see the
twist over horns there and I'm sure he's
doing some Forbes or some plants there
on the ground impalas being mixed
feeders and consider skin just twitching
the rosalie flex sometimes also the
flicking of the tail when they think
they got some either fly or the bites
sometimes it's always nothing and that's
when the oxpeckers come in very handy
when they cam like scissors beaks to get
oh the ticks out
so the two other peers in fellows of is
Walia to have a little fight that's
maybe trying to mock his area territory
they always so many are using the
forehead skin as crutch or just leaving
some scent behind and you can see him
just spelling to know that has left
something behind the forehead is full of
small guns and after he finishes to send
back you see him smelling maybe just to
confirm yes he has left enough scent
maybe of oh and the mayor's around here
he could be the main one and you can
tell from his display that's what they
call a proud posture he stands out there
you got a bush there from Jemima for a
little bit Oh still there yes and we had
some big some we're gonna move on in a
bit and see as you can see them a
different angle and there's some big
somewhere here
Taylor is asking me some very difficult
question and I'll give her a very
difficult answer in a few seconds that
Evo could have you know the magic power
as a guide yeah what what power I could
have I hope that just the Christian Lu
all right and sorry about my head there
I'm sure father is trying yeah we see
where you're going that's where they are
keep going well done we have some pigs
there yeah good job good job
and just thinking about how to answer
Taylor if this magic power
I think quotient what power let me see
is if I could be able to bring different
cuts and have a go on each other I'm
talking about lions and leopards have a
fight don't hurt each other or don't
kill each other and then have leopards
and cheetahs do the same and then they
go different ways and then mainly then
lastly have highness and lions going for
each other and maybe having in giraffe
as being a three that's what I'm
thinking if out of magical powers that's
what personally I would want to do foxes
that's a good idea you know have a whole
pride of lions will say free for
different you know male leopards and
have a go on each other
separate them after you know about 15
minutes and they'll have cheetahs one
sided leopards and then also have lions
and hyenas just in doing the same
exactly yeah foxes letting the arm
Olympics
do others go close to those pigs there
and find out if yeah all they're gonna
is gonna be skittish a oculus see
they always very skittish the warthogs
but this group family here that is
hanging around with impalas again safety
in numbers I'm gonna cynic on them very
quietly and I can see one fan when we
stop there and see it's looking
bothersome to piglets and there they are
not very far from impalas project alpha
how you and always wonderful to hear
your name you think the referees will be
the Zebras exactly because they're
already dressed nicely in black and
white very good very good and projects
althought want to ask you do you think
the officiating would be very fair
project alpha who do you think project
alpha I want to pose a question for you
if would give the Zebras as they much of
issues of if we don't count the zebra
now which animal do you think would be
the best match of issue which will not
favor you have always had of much fixing
you know in World Cups of champion
leagues and sometimes the referees have
been compromised and have been moved in
match fixing projects alpha of all the
animals you know in Africa which one do
you think two questions here it's gotta
be twofold question which one do you
think would be very easy to compromise
and which one do you think would be a
no-nonsense referee that will always be
fair to either team so which one do you
think which animal you think would be
compromised and move from the further
Control says cheetahs would be very easy
to compromise you have to explain you
have to convinced me why cheetahs would
be easy to compromise as you can see
that what of they are eating like
kneeling down and is exactly what I
expected to say and she is saying
because cheetahs are teachers and
they'll cheat and I think you could
appoint there
and you know we're changing the spots
and it will not change its spots
thank you [ __ ] I don't know what you
think about all cheaters yes what about
leopards maybe but projects alpha Liu
from the front of control have said
cheetahs will be easily compromised
please let me know what you think could
be unknown on sensitive free again it's
very free just like the cheetah to be
easily compromised and now because and
I'll move the eyes or move the head
nicely 360 baby
well [ __ ] things ours could make very
good references and non non sensitive
phrase because he thinks they're very
wise words what will be waiting to hear
from project alpha and maybe any other
viewer who may want to join in this well
nice viewers we got the final score now
and we think from today [ __ ] gets wild
dogs and wild dog has called sixth 1% on
the poll on Twitter so [ __ ] [ __ ]
Alex aka wild dogs I'm happy that all
right you could hear family background
saying oh yes and from now if you forget
to call you [ __ ] and it's a wild dogs
please just know I'll be referring to my
brother from another mother
by the name of fog but for now is why
the [ __ ] w d ha ha ha wd-40 says wd-40
like a [ __ ] fantastic you can see that
particular is a dremel and just flew on
top of that what over there and this one
can easily get its food why they'll
always be seen sometimes kneeling down
is to give them some good reverence to
be able to use the top mandibles to
uproot any you know rhizomes or any
roots they want but if comfortably they
can do that without dealing down they'll
just keep eating but once in a while
we'll see them going to their nails
I'm not sure that was trying to sniff
that's he and female or what is exactly
doing behind huh instead of eating well
you never know she flicks her tail and
keeps going because they don't give a
hoot why don't you agree than all give
me any early
please join join and let me know of the
team which one do you think could be
easily compromised and which one do you
think then ok lets rule out the Alpha
now which one do you think could be
easily Wow
[ __ ] wd-40 while dog feels thinks place
the Jota and yeah let me know who do you
think could be a no-nonsense Yuri free
this one now has gone down on sneeze
projectile found well done well done for
jet alpha I'm with you hundred percent
elephant's fantastic memories and you
can tell they don't forget very easily
they'll always have the rules of the
game in their mind if loads in their
pockets while British alpha I agree with
you and the card sometimes could be a
bit sneaky you've seen cuts on the hunt
how they behave projects alpha well wait
to hear what are the more viewers will
say but I agree with you elephants to me
all Louise no nonsense you've seen how
they behave when they're not happy and
when they're happy they're just very
easy to get along with yeah for what you
think project alpha say elephants yeah
fancy so and when they upset you hear
them you know making the trumpet call
and that's like every free when you get
one player playing funny and making a
foul he goes you know with the whistle
and the players trying to surround the
referee and he says get out get out of
here otherwise I am gonna give a red
could
alright this white oak continues eating
on the ground as ruff is also like this
what rock looking on the ground
well everyone we've just found a little
plant and it looks suspiciously like
wild cotton now I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I am almost certain
that it is now that's just some of the
the sort of pod that we've opened up but
let's show you the plant in its entirety
over here this is where it seems these
little pods have been opening up and you
can see on the outside there's the pod
with the very cotton wool top inside and
obviously here is one of the little pods
before they open up and that's quite
interesting indeed and I'm pretty sure
you would be able to use this too as
almost a form of cotton wool it's almost
identical in in in texture as well now I
hear you guys talking about superpowers
of what what you would need I think if I
have superpowers out yeah I'd like to be
able to fly just like even like a horn
ball just so that I could get up when
when we close to an animal when we hear
rasping from an from a lipid just to be
able to get up and very quickly be able
to see them that's what I would like to
be able to do it wouldn't break my life
so much easier knowing what I know and
how we track animals etc but this back
to this little plant also quite
indicative here it looks like it's got
poor mite palmate leaves because I was
showing you also some of the leaves this
is also compound it's a compound leaf as
that entire thing is one leaf but well
you can see it's got like five points to
it and so we call that a palm eight leaf
and so quite indicative as well I'm
pretty sure this is wild cotton but I'm
Amy best I can who be saying yeah he's
think so too
so let's go with that I'm interesting
hey nice little plant that we finding
around here in the winter months also
showing
it's it's some cotton and feels like
quite a lot of seeds inside that cotton
as well so I think that's how they
disperse it but not too much about it
you see as we're walking here as well
lots of these herbs or the wild basil
and very nice to rub in your hands they
are all seeding now at the moment mmm
wow that's very nice it's got an awesome
smell to it and one of them for wild
herbs that we do have around at the
moment also in the winter months so
we're just looking at all the little
things that we get around here in the
winter months because it seems like the
sites for the Cheetahs is now ended and
so what we're doing is we're heading
back towards Galago pan because it
sounds like there was some alarm calls
around lunchtime once again in a similar
area we Tandy's been hanging around so
whether or not she's returned there
remains to be seen but it's about that
time for her to start moving if it's her
otherwise it might also be ting garner
who knows but we hit him for that little
drainage line just between our camp and
Gallagher pan and we'll see if she
started to move him or her and hopefully
we get to follow up and try and find a
lipid that's what we're hoping for but
as I say always stopping for all these
little things in-between looking for the
interesting stuff now around this time
of year you know don't see these little
things in there in the summer months I
see here there's a nice example of of
what cheese's like a buffalo thorn yeah
it is the zz4 smoked Renata that's
obviously been broken off by an elephant
and he's been rolling that around in his
mouth turning that turning that and
almost grinding this off with his molars
as each turns it in his mouth and then
so he's after that that's exactly what
he's after it's probably quite tasty
especially now in the winter months this
is what the elephants start doing and a
very good reason why you start finding
they're down very red in color like this
and because it's that in a cambium
that inner the inner bark on the branch
which gets that red color see there and
say very similar to that of porcupine I
also get that red color to their dung
and a lot to do with that inner bark or
cambium of lots of branches and big
trees so yep that's it let's carry on
going heading down towards Galago pan
and see if we can pick up on any signs
of these lipids I think we're gonna join
you in the area let's see there's a
couple of birds yeah the barbets are
probably going to be the most well
behaved so we can maybe try have a look
at them but some know where they're
going come back of course this is like I
said this is my luck with the animals
this week it's getting old
come on animals be kind but thank you
Bob a day we are just hopping around so
we I think we're gonna go and join Ralph
from the area because we are coming up
to retail it down we just in the
molarity and then I think we'll head
drawn that way to have a little scratch
nice little bird party so there were two
Kristin barbets
then there was a flock of for a gang
should I say a very marked babblers is
another barber over there alright so
they just drop down there feeding here
can they see you else we've got I can
hear chatters of other things to look
like again there on the sandpaper
raisins there might be a few fruits
around that's a tree that you can see
was sort of the little green knees on it
we were watching a bother do that even
this morning action bush walk very
briefly we had a I'm gonna crystal
bubble really close to us and it was
investigating on a sandpaper raisin
there it is again
looking for looking for things I don't
know if it's trying to get insects maybe
I mean I haven't really seen much fruit
on the sandpaper raisins anymore they
seem to have all been finished but maybe
if you search carefully there might be
one that's a little bit sort of late
bloomer and that would be a tasty snack
for the bar 'but well so this gives us
an opportunity to listen out for any
alarm port
I didn't hear something snorting
I know me that is I think it could be it
may have been an empire and it's still a
couple of them are making the sort of
gurgling noises snorting sounds wait
let's see once you can get the babblers
let's go a bit further forward cuz
they've jumped into a tree maybe we'll
get them in the next one yeah well
hoppin I know there
there's a few of them they just sort of
bouncing around at the moment
I think it's just flowing to the right
hey they are then there in that shrub
just over there and that way have you
seen on there didn't I pass you in that
way oh this quad is insane yeah Shh
so to the left and then down there we go
they are there in in there some way I
can just see them bouncing around every
now then you can hear them they see
there you go you should see the wings
fluttering around this is the kind of
luck that I'm having I'm very sorry
hopefully hopefully in the next few days
my my luck is gonna change I don't even
show you birds properly there's a couple
they're all bouncing around someone has
flown to the top of a of a tree I don't
know if you can see it's really there we
go there is a error box babble affinely
but it's a silhouetted version of an era
ma babbler again we will keep moving and
head towards Gallagher to help find out
about what's causing the stir David has
got a few of the sudden
one of the best moments I love being out
in wilderness is what you see on your
screen and just watching what wild dog
was that your correct name fog oh yes
wild August a new name very good not fog
anymore just what he has set up for you
there and what I've always thought is a
little natural framing of a sunset and
when you just sit somewhere and you
watch the western horizon in the African
wilderness life could not be better they
always see the sound slowly going down
and setting on the western horizon of
all the beautiful colors you'd think of
it always marks the end of a great day
very good bus flowing in front of it and
Louie the final control says that is
beautiful truly that's just wonderful
and we just buy the twin word whole area
sorry about my head and you can see the
reflection of that tree in the water
there just looks like a movie set very
very good job very good job wild dog the
only thing we need to see there is maybe
some lizards like you know monitor
lizard swimming in the water see how the
waves are changing the ships of the tree
is a reflection of the tree there some
fish I think could be breathing down
there in a catfish or mud fish you can
see the bubbles coming up
so the only other thing could maybe want
is to have a set with Ellie's coming
down for a drink
excuse me and just walking on the water
whole wall sounds slowly and surely
setting in and going down what have you
just that fantastic
couldn't be better
very good we need to make a move when do
you say you love that reflection and I'm
sure gonna say to you again Wendy that's
a great reflection Wendy and wild dog
will shoot you again [ __ ] a koala dog
why don't you show it again don't worry
Wendy don't look at my head just look at
the reflection there sure my head
doesn't make a very good a screen
picture and Wendy if you can why don't
you take that one ours are your screen
saver Wendy just look at that just spend
in a few 10-15 seconds of silence
and it's not only me and wild dog here
who are enjoying the sunset but we've
got another team who are like wow what a
sunset well gosh come come come come
because I want to show you something
that if you don't know what I was
talking about earlier with that very
small dung that we had we had to
remember add a card um tiny little dung
like that we had impala done which was
medium-sized and then a little bit
bigger than that
niala / kudu now when we were dealing
with the small little dung remember I
said there's two animals that have very
small little dung pellets like that one
being the Steinbach but they bury it and
the other one being the duiker and that
one that we had on the road there was a
daycare because it didn't have any signs
of sand on it or anything like that it
was also art in the open when we found
it but what I'm showing you here is just
where my stick is moving it's on the
inside of this and if you look very
closely what you've actually seen here
is a scrape there a scrape there and a
scrape there leaving this big pile of
sand here and if we just start to dig
into the sand look what we start to see
is nice little small little dung peanuts
now this is what the little Steinbach
has done in an attempt to bury his dung
so you would do that those scrapes with
the front feet and well he hasn't done
an amazing job of it but she has buried
quite a bit of it and I'm just exposing
now a little bit as well so there you
can see the classic Steinbach bury sight
of there down so well if you have seen
it before it's it's always nice to see
because I've seen this countless times
but it still amazes me how a little
antelope can bury its down why would
they do that well they're done
particularly that's obviously an
evolutionary trait and in a survival
strategy what you know not giving away
exactly where they move
because they do move around a very
similar area all the time and obviously
makes them very susceptible to predators
so if they bury their down maybe their
predators the little predators like
caracal and even leopard and jackals etc
would find it difficult for them to to
find their little routine and so they
have thought of that strategy or moved
along instinctively with that kind of
strategy and also looks like it's been
digging here the same animal I would
suggest maybe for a little of these
bulbous type plants this looks like some
kind of wild onion I would think some
kind of little Anki as we would say in
Afrikaans or a little wild onion
possibly but I think definitely just
getting down to those little UT areas
and the some of the little antelopes can
do that day care as well and porcupines
would obviously be ones that could
definitely be going for lots of roots at
the moment and I think that there's a
Steinbach moving around here quite
regularly and well we can see the signs
so that's it right I think it's back
time to move back down towards Galago
pen see if Tandy Otunga Ana are making
an appearance the Sun is heading towards
the horizon so we don't have too long
now Cristina you say that's a lot of
dung yes the steam box they can go back
and use the same spot quite a few times
and then they'll continue to bury it now
you see here almost identical a little
bit of a slightly different color on it
there but this is nicely exposed so that
just literally what are we not even 20
metres away from that Steinbach madam
here we've got a little darker spot
where they have been defecating on the
surface so very similar type habitat
very similar habits that these two
creatures
perform but just a slightly different
survival strategy in where they defecate
and how they do it
so that's nice tonight between daycare
and Steinbach and the little Angela
of this particular zone is some more
over here so it is also a takers little
latrine area I would say there's another
nice big pile there of daycare done so
yeah very interesting and nice to see
the signs of these two little enter life
moving in exactly the same area and
probably you know fulfilling quite the
same similar role in this area too now
Larry some of the Predators
they will bury their dung I think some
of the smaller predators you know
jackals for instance they don't bury
their young they very much like the
Mongoose where they try and actually
defecate on something that unlocks and
posts and on elephant dung they also do
it on top of Rana middens so it you know
the higher the dung site the almost the
bigger the animal seems they've got a
little bit of what I would say small man
syndrome because Mongoose do it as well
they'll try and back up onto a termite
mound and try and defecate as high as
possible and then that would make them
seem to be quite a lot bigger as well so
they do that but I don't know of the
caracal I think the caracal also do
defecate on the surface I don't know of
any natural predators maybe maybe the
little African Wildcat because that's
been you know sort of domesticated into
our normal common domestic cat now so
the African wild cats I think might
scrape over it's it's scat
but this not all of the Predators will a
leopard lion hyenas they defecate on the
surface hyenas can do it in a particular
spot sometimes but leopard and lion they
definitely don't bury these but well
speaking of lion and leopard I'm still
hoping that we're gonna hear one very
soon
Ralph I'm counting on you this evening
to hear a leopard sawing for me and then
I'm gonna be in the area while I'm in
the area now I'm just approaching gotta
go pad and AH entire herd of elephants
have moved through here at some point
but you think that I can find them no
they've been going up and down I think
they may have gone to drink and then I
think they came back a sort of a similar
way so we just have a look around you
maybe we'll go around and check I don't
know we will check see yeah these tracks
are going straight towards the pan so
here's Galago pan
it's have a little listen I'm 40 other
babblers
I think I heard one what do you think
Craig it's so quiet except i think i
heard an elephant maybe it specially
around yeah it is very it's deathly
quiet
no sawing leopards oh this is such a
good spot at the moment for animals
they're all hanging around here please
and a fern just one I think I say no I
was so spoiled this morning and spent
the majority of the walk with him on
foot that was such a cool sighting this
morning I could read he was and that's
one of any idea into the top ten
elephant encounters I've had on foot
definitely
I've had some crackers this year shake
wonder what that sound was it I don't
listen again maybe make the same sound
I was very quiet not even any birds yeah
you're the babblers and the distance you
need all sorts of things
okay I don't know where that thing was
and what it was not me that sounded like
I don't know every what like an yeah
flapping against the elephant's body and
what else could be that sound I don't
see any elephant tracks aside though but
maybe they moved in here maybe we'll
catch them going across quarantines not
oh how does silhouetted elephant sound
that's a great idea now if the animals
can hear me hopefully they can hopefully
they give you on the obliging side of
things I don't know I haven't seen one
nape attract ah
other than some some old ones on Triple
Aim I think I've forgotten either
identify elite track two it's been such
a long time hmm maybe there goes sneaky
sneaky sneaky elephant's cake and it's
keep checking up here Oh birds
and a real no hey I think another
question and also asked animals if they
get bored you know I think gets bored I
wonder if they're little elephant and
well they look just the little elephants
but the young animals get bored and I
suppose they want to just play all the
time and it must be frustrating for them
and nobody really wants to play with
them but I don't I don't know if they
know understand the concept of boredom
it's um it's very difficult to sort of
say I think with aren't verbally asking
the animal and it's responding
appropriately I mean there might be some
theories around it
well than any that I've ever read though
but again there are many research papers
there suppose you're out in the wild I
don't think wild animals would
necessarily get bored maybe animals in
captivity confined space is unable to
move a lot they could probably get bored
but I'd sure I think everybody's so busy
just focusing on making sure that they
eat enough because remember animals in
captivity are well everyone's got set
times as to when they get fed they
guaranteed a meal every day or every
second oh I suppose it depends on the
species say so so it's a tough one but I
chair it's hard work I mean an elephant
is basically gathering all day long
making sure it's got enough to eat
you're going to search for water same
thing goes for a and parler a wildebeest
of course the animals that are ruminants
they need to make sure that they spend
time and regurgitating and and then of
course reaching the cut so they've all
got lots of things do lions need to make
sure that they've consumed enough energy
so that they'll be able to successfully
hunt down prey so no I don't think wild
animals get bored it's just too much on
their on their plates very busy okay
when are we gonna find some animals
we're on open plains of quarantine now
and there's still nothing trying to
think what mammals I've seen today I saw
a warthog bottom ran away and then
that's pretty much all I've really seen
in terms of mammoth oh one horn Shawnee
Impala and a couple of in yada hidden in
the thickets here in there anyways so I
was a tree house down a little bit
there was nothing but a blacksmith left
wing you see what David as then your
tailor that's the how gamblers got
sometimes just by the draw of the game
and we are just watching beautiful
setting ourselves the Sun has gone and
another beautiful affection of trees in
the water hall where we are the three
watt hall and a thing with some
blacksmith droppings in the background
and as you saw the blacksmith's lapis is
just here on the very edge of the water
they rarely go into the water
and they'll be feeling on any aquatic
organisms they can reach either the
surface but occasionally dipping their
beaks right inside and they very
diversified on how they eat because they
not only eat the aquatic organism the
water but at times you see the way far
away from the water and they'll be
feeling also on terrestrial be they
insect or something like that
they'll necessarily water organisms but
more from the not you'll see them you
can see how the diffraction showing one
lapping up then going down and then they
are meeting in the water
good job are then walldog excellent very
monogamous lagoons are there always have
the nest not far from the water
Ashley thank you very much
wild dog is doing a fantastic job and I
think one of the reasons why he is
overdoing all you know doing himself
it's just because of his new name
actually yeah he says absolutely and
actually thank you very much and he's so
proud of his name and maybe very soon we
are going to start a process of having
his names also changed on his passports
for anything with our Fogg
oh yeah because that's now will also
increase your job rating in safari life
and you know you've become one of the
best camera operators around well done
all right he says operating room flight
and excellent we're gonna be making a
move and find out what is still ahead of
us and well done
all dog and excellent let's move forward
and seahorse is waiting for us we still
got a good time and good light to keep
hunting
crepuscular animals good time for them
not to be coming out anything that's
always between dusk and dawn this is the
right hour for them to come out and
either start stretching start feeding
stretch moving around
Debra how are you today and you're
asking me what a vice the price would
have suppressed me the most in Juma and
is a very straightforward answer the
number of leopards I've seen here I mean
I've been here now about two months and
I've seen loads of leopards and where I
come from in East Africa
it's my tickers about a month to see one
leopard and here Deborah I would say is
every two three days leopard leopard
every 2-3 days leopard and certain days
like yesterday we had two leopards in
one day while and not very far from each
other
so Deborah leopards have been something
pretty special for me something they're
gonna remember when I go back to East
Africa and if you compare the two places
the huge difference between here and
East Africa is the amount of game when
we see like thousand for example the
migration will come so when I think of
any big difference between here and East
Africa will be the amount of say the
will is to be saying but yes I've seen
loads of leopards here the last two
months have been here and that has been
very special for me
Deborah have you been to Africa before
do you plan to come and visit as one of
the days since go out with us on a
safari
let me know when you can us we move
along
and as usual keep your eyes on the
ground on the very soft sand this is
what will always give away the cuts when
you pick up the trucks you know there's
no one direction to keep going at the
keep going or turn around or look if
they disappear to the right you have
your eyes focused there so with your
cameraman you've got four eyes to look
at you support something beautiful thank
you very much
someone dying yeah we are dying kid you
know we have footage arrived I'm gonna
sit and wait and I have to park like 600
kilometres away from it because it just
keeps running away and then when I
stopped I thought he was gonna carry on
walking like he's doing now but he then
stopped and pause for a little bit
behind the tree and that gorgeous though
there's fur lovely honey was going to go
for a drink at the pan maybe that'll be
nice is the nest cam working imagine if
a giraffe goes and drinks to get those
sort of shots that would be wonderful
no he's hiding even a giraffe can be
camouflaged and it is a male I'm telling
you that because I'm looking at its
ossicones and his his rather large sort
of very bumpy head that he has he's not
walking not quite towards us but at
least not going to be able to hide away
in the distance that's a very very
pretty scene I kill to get an idea of
how tall some of the trees are and is a
dwarf DaSilva class Denis that he's just
walking behind another sort of Eccleston
Eve destroyed by elephants
look a tree that's been pushed down I
wonder which animal did that
that's quite gorgeous they're very sort
of dark contrasting trees with the
yellow grass and the few bits of
greenery here and there Oh stopping to
have a nibble on guess a silver fast to
leave note like that one you might get a
silhouetted giraffe that might work in
our favor so it was a very busy Drive
he's moving around quite a bit
he's gonna disappear behind a big marina
where we parked against a marina no of
course he's going to feed there now let
me let me reposition us quickly make
sure there's no more marinas that I can
reverse into haha
spy on him through the scat no please
please stand still cuz now I can't get
you nice coat wool Craig can't get you
nice close intimate shots because he
just doesn't want to see us he's not
even looking at us he's looking
everywhere else but at us he's always
here reacting to the car so I'm giving
him space please draw pause for like two
seconds he's eating now nibbling on
something again it's not that we have to
keep Park quite far away revenger you're
quite correct and saying and what a sort
of beautiful scene it was it was it was
all very very lovely I like it when a
giraffe walks in an open area and there
are a few trees because you can realise
how tall the trees are but you've seen
us standing under them I'm enjoying also
the technique that the giraffe is using
which is the typical and technique that
you're after used to eat which is of
course using those three long tough
tongues to wrap around a branch and
simply just pull up and strip all the
leaves off and that tree is working very
well because there's no thorns on it so
it's a bush roll of sorts maybe a little
rush resset mushroom variable so I can't
really see the leaves very well from
here mm-hmm
russet psycho acid push water and
or four guys again going to camp now in
the direction of camp very indecisive
it's some doing the zigzag motion
perhaps it's note that because I think
we trans exact towards truffle the time
try and get him to see what we are
enjoying get another view of him arts a
pity now there's there's no there's no
roads that cut in the side that would've
been great to get a silhouette shot
anyways this Rafa is walking back
towards camp and that's what Ralph is
doing too well yes we have been walking
back towards camp but we here at Canada
pan which is right next to Gallagher
Lodge now I remember I did say that
we're coming to find out whether Tandy
Orton Ghana has been moving around yeah
because we did hear some alarm calls
around lunchtime and it wasn't far from
here that we saw her a couple of nights
ago and she was moving around and right
around the lodge and it seems trying to
hunt to one of those little bush buck or
niala that do like hanging around the
lodge with the nice sprinklers and the
lovely grass etc that's available for
them so timely not stupid as well she
knows that that's where is some easy
food is to be gotten but we haven't
heard anything for now and while it
still remains a mystery if she's headed
back this way or if she's headed up
towards tweet Columba is haven't been
spotted today so no we I think we're
gonna have to wait until tomorrow now
because it's getting a little bit late
as you can see that Sun is set so it's
not long and we will be heading back
towards camp as per usual when you're
out on foot once that Sun hits the
horizon you want to be heading back to
where your safe zone is and this is the
time when the Predators are going to
start walking around as well so that's
one of the reasons why we also go to our
safe spot and take it nice and easy now
it seems like Terra's got something
exciting to show you
and I'm gonna say goodbye and see you
tomorrow
barbar I'll see you later and now we can
play game very quickly
hashtag safari live let me know what
bird do you think this is it's a silly
way to challenge it's an easy one I just
want to see if everybody's still awake
and paying attention so first one into a
type watch bird this is you will not win
a prize but you of course get bragging
rights that you won the silhouette a
bird challenge two dates like I said
it's an easy one it should you should be
able to get that quite easy some birds
are very very easy to introduce huh
louise has given her guess but she
doesn't hunt because she didn't use the
hashtag Safari live haha or the YouTube
chat hello we just wait YT and awkwardly
I'm citizen silently pray God your
offers back hi giraffe are you coming in
to play the silhouette challenge as well
it's just walking across it might be a
beautiful view once again walking among
some of the bigger trees that's a big
jackal berry it's just past and then
some sort of cluster to be used lots of
silver cluster you see on this open area
they like the sandy soils and then of
course the rulers but they're still
taller than this giraffe even if it
would stand on its back legs
these trees are massive here really
really big and just pausing having a
little look around this rod is doing
what we actually wanted to do because in
about 200 meters we could get a
silhouette of it well done Kathy giraffe
and giraffe girl and Izzy your guest
Lana crested roller you win the prize of
not winning a prize tonight because you
know this is not the Ellen Show sadly
anyways Oprah Winfrey
everybody look under your seats you look
anyone you look anyone that was always
my favorite
anyways let's see come on I'm gonna can
she not going to let this giraffe get
away from us we will we will be getting
a silhouette shot of the draw you just
got to be patient he is about to cross
the road I was telling you about we can
go down at now just don't go down
towards Kim come back up this way police
truck
I'm also hanging around you because I
want to see the honey badgers and the
white-tailed Mongoose and this
crepuscular period so that the last
little bit of light is normally when
they get active
don't you dare draft going around
Ferrari Safari yeah
it was gonna get too low and then we
were never gonna get the silhouette that
I wanted lots of trees in the way
no this stream I'm trying to find the
gap oh maybe bush press that way I can
get a whirl around the trees otherwise
you're not gonna see this sort of weight
at all I mean it's not great but it will
do actually maybe you know maybe it was
gonna be nice there is almost a
silhouette of a giraffe still a little
bit light perfect now we still need to
achieve our goal of it is very beautiful
looks like the disguise on fire behind
the trees and they've all been burnt but
I'm still holding lumps cuz there are
some parler around maybe just maybe one
afternoon we will get those and part are
bounding up and down remember like I
said I've always wanted to see
silhouetted Impala leaping as high as
they can leap but I haven't found any
Impala but if we take this bottom road
all the way around we probably actually
weren't you gonna win the silhouette
challenge today I always liked taking
silhouette pictures of animals one of my
favorite things and it's not very common
our thing if we actually go all the way
around we might win and catch it again
and we're going quite lone as you can
see we're sort of going downhill and
then that your Arthur's going to be up a
little bit higher all the Impala and
wildebeest are on their way up to the
open area so if King Ghana or somebody
of the leopard or anything comes walking
around maybe they'll chase them in
parlor would you like to go and bound
and the sunset for us would you ones
running but I don't think he's gonna
jump high enough they're just you just
get trotting trotting and Pilar keep
going that way
like I said we still gonna have a little
bit of light for a while we could
achieve our goal our there is actually
he's gonna get into a much better spot
now
it would have been nice if we could have
timed it perfectly of course with a
sunset oh there is a herd of Impala okay
already
another group you mean lots and lots of
Impala lots and lots of food
Roberts yes scientist I think they're
quite gracious when they walk people
when they're run that's quite nice a
cowl stop yeah we can just appreciate
the animals there's lots of them now
you've got the Impala again then maybe
something frightens those I'm Harland
and they leap up and then I've achieved
my goal I mean it's so quiet it's very
nice
well there's the pink hue in the sky
very pretty
stopping for a bit of a snack the
draught doesn't seem to be too
interested in feeding though for long
periods of time and of course the
giraffe is going to do that hiding
behind the marula and you have some
Franklin shouting no
the leopard soars I'm gonna find it and
I'm right here at camp and I'm hoping
ting garner will be out calling I didn't
think he's been seen anywhere else so
the possibility is that he's still
around you on the property somewhere
okey-dokey well we'll carry on doing a
couple of laps around and hoping to find
a leopard turning David's good juvenile
bird of sorts all right
we could a rafter I have not seen ruff
trust the last three four days and I
want us to have a small dog ID I want
all of us to try and identify which bad
of prey is this remember zushio look on
the shape of the head look on the colors
they don't look you know very very clear
they're not very conspicuous I'll only
give you one hint it's is it an immature
one no is a juvenile it's just turning
from an immature to a juvenile bad of
prey or to a juvenile you know ruff ha
so it's not immature per se
on the ship of the head luke'll the
color of the beak and look on the
breasts and the wing feathers not very
clear like a scut as they face down look
at the eyes he's you know the size and
how she is looking and let's think or
guess Ravine de african hawk eagle very
good yes very good guess but not quite
ravine de but well done but look at how
the feathers are sticking behind her
head the world and ravine de and have a
hidden Ravinder is always a pleasure to
hear your name ravine de you such a
great viewer see the fellas sticking out
of her head there the color and see she
got a hooked beak just turned from
immature to a juvenile you know kind of
one thing is certain you know she's an
ego let's start from there she's an ego
she's keep you know keeping looking and
one more hint they take such a long time
for them to get the plumage of fully
grown adult before they get all the
colors there was you see the snake eagle
not really but very good very good very
good gas it's very similar to what you
call a brown snake hero Thomas it's very
similar to a brown snake eagle but not
quite so I give you all a very important
hint this is one ego that takes such a
long time sometimes up to seven years to
reach an adult plumage which is always
some bright red on the face black height
Zach very well done Zach very well done
use its butt Leah no doubt about it is a
juvenile bustling a wall down Zach
excellent and a big applause for you
well done thank you so very much so
you'd imagine if you see a fully grown
Butler ego how it looks and that's to me
a juvenile one because was there from
small chips they got a matures and then
from there they go to juveniles I'll try
and see what I can guess my book and fog
will tell me how good the light will be
for us yeah
keep enjoying that and then try and get
the egos and I'll show you how another -
looks like already taking your time
pitiful and you can imagine how the
fully grown different it will be to the
immature ones righty
all righty you thank you very much
hakuna matata loon I just want to show
you [ __ ] you let me know where they have
some good light there and good and see
what you just saw there and if we're
gonna show you here very top number one
excellent very good job and that is the
VATS lure eagle and very well down Zach
well done you got right and what we just
watch now is that one there too right
the JC is good angle there it's down a
bit that way very good thank you fog
thank you all dog and what you see on
the right the JC now that's a juvenile
Jane for juvenile and the water is left
would be out today you know the image
will now look like the fully grown ones
that's a number one there then you see
the colors they got and from the JC
there to the number one it takes seven
years to attain those color said I'm not
sure I know of any other Eagles that
takes such a long time to get to those
colors why it takes so many years I have
no idea and I'd be more than happy to
know how it takes so long and if you
look carefully I can show that there is
the female and you can always tell the
filler from the male and the thing the
juvenile one there was a female and you
will always tell from the outer covers
there that the Hoyt and you're always
joke and say the alike wearing petticoat
when you remember way back you know
garlic in the village we know we are
pretty good and you will see the whites
cut that's how you tell from the field a
male from female
fantastica
for me it's a good question and you're
asking you know when do they become
independent that's particular on their
as we move on I think it's my ticket
okay Luis hurry okay bring your question
again do is sorry
all right our guests Louise you want to
know one do it the bunny has become
independent will I know this for sure I
would say it to take maybe the same time
as long as they also take you know to
get the plumage it also takes a long
time for them to get independent maybe a
couple of years but I can get you the
exact answer later tonight Lu but I used
to be happy to know but what I know for
a fox is they take such a long time or
the seven years I said to get to that
plumage [ __ ] how does the moon look does
it look very good or is it too far yeah
I'll be more than happy if you could
somebody look and it looks rather than
last night we saw it here sorry but I
think today it looks more colorful how
is that beautiful sky thank you very
much yeah I mean the finer controls is
beautiful we always very lucky in Africa
or sunrises always fantastic the sunsets
our Lucy great people now look at their
crescent of the moon you know all this
gives me over the crest for animals
Crepuscule animals should be coming out
it's a very good tilt of day and night
there should be out ready to either come
feeling very good job [ __ ] who do not
want to see that in such a clear sky lit
cloud when we start to begin revenue in
the morning we thought it would rain the
clouds who are building it was a bit
gray and in the afternoon you are
debating we put a roof on or not then
just found out it just cleared and to go
better
all right very good factor things tend
to look for the night animals now what
do you think Yoga good Christian desta
Foreman affects the animal's behavior we
saw for example during the writing
season about a month and a month and a
half ago after in May when the impalas
were rotting they started writing
between the first sight of the full moon
and they stopped at the end of the full
moon and it's always very difficult to
see impalas you know meeting because
they're always late at night you know in
the moonlight so it depends on what
you're looking at but you found out
sometimes some cats like lions or little
birds will take advantage of such wound
or when the moon is full and it's bright
enough and they can see they still see a
little bit better than the antelopes or
than the prey so yes yoga ETFs their
behavior and they tend to move most of
the cuts for hunting what I've always
known this times way back when we had
issues with poachers we used to have
what we call the the poachers moon and
the poachers who always come out at
night and do the posses but then luckily
now we have very good game Rangers and
that has since been contained I might be
wrong but I'm trying to look through
some bushes here and you might tell me
whether is a buffalo I am seen from a
distance and you allow me when you can't
and when you come back to me we'll move
a little bit forward and we'll just look
you see that opening there I'll move for
a bit and we just confirm what it is let
me just move forward a bit I could be
seeing a bush and I'm saying I'm seeing
a buffalo you never know you know with
all this with the new name I give you
let's find out something duck I'm not
sure it's moving or not but it looks
like a buffalo let's turn the direction
and see you see there [ __ ]
okay let me go a little closer let's be
like a lone Buffalo which I'm sure draft
would not have wanted to see on foot hi
dad stop here move forth a little bit
back all right no worries [ __ ] that's
good okay Buffalo via and I would be
wrong but outs in 99% chances it is a
male buffalo yes now that confirms do
you hear me
alrighty and look at how he's looking at
us very mean and we've now just going to
infrared
thank you very much [ __ ] you look at him
how mean they are always the son of the
animals you play about with and very
easily they can just bring you down
without warning hello mister Buffalo you
have a good life living with females and
youngsters and one time you're only on
when you shown the door and that's for
that reason they become very grumpy and
I was talking about how he pulls a
pretty dangerous in the village he come
from but apart from the hippos buffaloes
also caused a lot of damage
Kathy good Christian what all the
greatest do for food when the grass dies
and most of them now what is that dream
this that digging you know the grass
dies on top but beloit the tubers all
the roots are still holding lots of food
but the stem is sort of much in value so
they tend to dig will select animals
like you know Buffalo's or zebras which
are like barking grazers they tend to D
order to be found in the underground but
other animals for example elephants we
have seen elephants are very clever they
will knock trees down and you know get
the roots down but also we have see them
getting the twigs or the branches and
thus keep rolling them in the mouth and
eating the back of the trees all righty
and then once the rains come around
August all will be good
joy excellent very good to see you know
buffaloes
again and hopefully they'll bring the
Lions mark yes that should be exciting
and I'm sure you know a week ago we had
Buffalo that was brought down by the new
comers so it's a blessing to have the
Buffaloes back and maybe the lanes will
come again we'll have one more quick
look of this Buffalo before no one we
just have one more quick tip on the
Buffalo we just come a little bit closer
and he's just staring at us and as you
want to leave you Malone he doesn't
charge to us we'll be going across to
the beautiful Taylor McCurry luffa Din
there oh so smooth yes David is quite
smooth isn't he
we might have been dry dry friend again
because he seen his tracks around here
I'm walking this direction maybe he's
already got a go pan having a little bit
of a drink
but we're driving very slowly and it's
getting really cold I made a mistake of
not bringing my big jacket out or a
scarf tonight I actually don't know what
I was thinking I normally don't ever
leave them without scarf today let me
just take it easier the area for
nocturnal creatures from servants that
do you like to feed in sort of drainage
lines to honey badgers who spend a fair
amount of time moving through those
areas and then Bush babies will be nice
so I'm going to check in some of the
holes and the trees Janet's all these
wonderful things let's see if we're
gonna be in luck tonight and manage to
find any hopefully weird yeah ideal I
can hear a few bats too these little
high-pitched chirping noise that they do
me for they're flying around it'll be
very difficult to try and predict that
on camera it's not impossible but it's
definitely one of the more challenging
things and especially when there's just
one zipping around sometimes when there
was a bit of a feeding frenzy going on
I'm actually surprised you don't see
more bats at Chitra dad because
love to eat mosquitoes and often in the
evenings or the last few evenings when
you go there there's a mess of
mosquitoes swarming above your head I
can't believe we don't see the bats
maybe a little bit later in the evening
perhaps I I've always been at the dam a
but too early for them okay we're about
to arrive at Gallagher pan again Louise
just said that sometimes is a back that
gets stuck in our bathroom so I've never
seen that wonderful I have yet to see
their bed okay they just have a quick
look here shake loose just told me that
Alicia who also works for this and she's
all American and she chef Andy wake you
up very early in the morning once
because the bat was and then she was too
scared to go in I would have loved to
have seen that that have been very very
funny oh yeah we're gonna see how Emma
and Jenna behave not behave react to the
interesting creatures that venture on
into the GRC I wonder who will scream
louder when they encounter the first
their first experience with the son of
usurer SunSpider red roman you've got a
variety of different names those things
that look like spiders but on spiders
but they're quite creepy they're always
really funny when they're come racing
into your room there's nothing there's
nothing slow-moving about a about a red
Roman either or a solid fusion and what
else the centipede because we get some
monster centipedes that come through all
when they see the big mumble notes
Mozambique spitting cobra that's the
living under the windy house when that
comes out every now and then doesn't
cause us any hassles it just lives there
to be to get nice and warm of course oh
we will see we will see who's screams
allowed us so I'll get back back to you
on that
ah very nice I don't know how David has
been so lucky today with all the mammals
because he's got another one is quite
shy well sometimes of the sadie's know
the luck of the draw or what the bush
throws out you turn the right corner on
something where it comes up and now we
got a Steinbach after having seen a huge
male Buffalo we have seen a smaller top
and this is a stay Bach always very shy
and I like you know Buffalo's you might
see in hard three four five even if
their owners it's small you guys here
will always be on their own
I know same book and I've admired seeing
them because of the size is on that it's
a bit dark now but one of the best
things they love them for other ears how
they look very painted brother doctor
see now and he is slowly making his way
in the bushes to see to unless a male
and female hallo or Marvin a youngster
but always very solitary browse us again
feeling a little leaves or when you see
them in the ground will be digging for
some food and they tend to be active
like now before the gets little darker
and they know the security might be at
risk and then the slow down and just
stay somewhere for the night they always
have the Barrows or warrants where they
make them and then they establish some
territories and very unusual to see
males and females overlapping and you'll
see a male just living next to a female
and they will not come into contact for
any one reason they don't even wave at
each other until when it comes to mating
time you'll see the male sneaking to the
female how does that sound father
yeah our typical miles for wild dog
while dog says for initial I'm not sure
in my next life I want to be Steinbach
Ian thank you very much
Davis Dannemora I think it had been more
of a combination of luck a bit of skill
but the person who brought the
difference I think sphuck and as soon as
they give Fogg his new name Black has
been following us even though our point
what is he [ __ ] no father I think you
know and also it happens fun oh yeah oh
and he always have very good eyes [ __ ]
and yeah so lights back again Thank You
Steinbach and I was saying earlier I'm
not sure in my next life I would want to
be a Steinbach just living on your own
you know it's a bit difficult when you
don't associate or relate with someone
only during you know when you're meeting
after that's you're living your life
here how would you like to be as 10 Bach
you not stick the world again very good
ok
Fox jaiswal dog and I don't think he
would want to be a saint Bach very
lonely
I don't know watch these spends the day
thinking [ __ ] you thinking well keep to
the wild dog and that should be more
less like it's just raining my lights on
the bushes to chance maybe on a
chameleon or a bush baby jumping up and
down this is very good time to sport
these primates coming out you always see
their red eyes in the bushes or scrub
hands alright of them still good
Niger's way on the road
fantastic I had gone a small your
drainage there and they lost voter
losses my signal but so far so good
that's what you tell and see whether
she's seen anything in the dark or not
not yet we're gonna go what is that
sound I don't know there's something
rattling in this car and I can't figure
out what it is anyway so I'm going to
try and block it out ah believe somebody
thought it was a cell phone that was
ringing might be my flaws No
see if that works stopped for now we'll
see when we go over a bumpy area we
normally hear you know was not a
cellphone I don't even know what my
ringtone is my phone lives on silent
these days Craig do you not your
ringtone is be also crakes is not sure
we're so used to having our phones on
silent pretty much all the time of
barely barely barely take it out of out
of silent right
please can we see a seventh this evening
I've seen a servant in such a long time
it's really been ages but there could be
quite cool I'm trying to drive these
these obviously these roads that run
along the Milwaukee River system for
hours and all sorts of wonderful things
this is an interesting one from Andy
about which which guide to the wild
does the wildlife troll the most um Andy
well it depends they like to pay the
disappearing hideaway game for me or
don't stand still fly away that's the
game they play with me with James they
like to play the game of its use the
luxury facilities all the time every
time he sees an animal they either start
urinating or defecating which is a
standing joke around camp which is quite
funny all the time it happens Tim and
and then I don't bring you know other
wildlife plagues anybody else but no it
goes through stages which sometimes it's
really good sometimes it's not so good
what all those little eyes in here and
these cookie check I don't know if it is
anything be a good area to see something
though could be maybe a little Janet
moving in and out of these thickets
I mean if I were one of the nocturnal
creatures will probably be here ah
lovely lori i wish your dream came true
the faculty dreamt that I found a honey
badger I wish maybe that's going to
happen tonight
I'd be very excited if that were the
case no I don't know we have be very
short on sort of nocturnal creatures up
here we know that there yeah you just
don't ever get to see them it's bizarre
it's totally bizarre is to see so
mentioned down south porcupine and he
Badgers eating in all the Rhino middens
all the time seeing lots of I tell
mongers we've got incredible sightings
of whitetail Mongoose and the Mara
I even had a whitetail mungus scavenging
on a wildebeest carcass which was
bizarre that is so cool
I mean obviously you know a lot of
animals are opportunistic feeders but it
was the first time I'd ever seen a
white-tailed mombi's like physically
well I was feeding on the meat it was so
amazing and so that was that was nice
definitely got lots and lots of
sightings there and even my freakin wild
cat in the Mara - and moths down on the
southern side we have sad anyways
they're nocturnal critter that is very
common but we've been yet to find but of
course David the animal finder has got
it
well another luck here with a scrub hair
very common in this area and nocturnal
definitely looking for food and maybe
feeling almost the whole night they
smell good dry not palatable before you
want you should dig something from the
ground scrub here's maybe their skin
until she is convinced what she wants
and the right quality always coming out
at night does it again as I say the beef
in there you know through the night
going back early morning keeping away
from the Predators well the results will
come out at night
hopefully they're not seen or supported
by their would-be predators and also see
cheetahs or leopard but still once in a
while they are brought down huge ears
they got they need to hear very well and
of course can see the big eyes I tried
to charge us so where were you going
still not very happy with what is on the
menu
she keeps spelling skills moving until
she be convinced what's good for her I'm
not sure that's the best way to look for
food they normally eat here for
something nice at least to enjoy there
are some leaves of some kind from that
formed
most of them having dried up maybe
that's who the challenge she is facing
not sure exactly what to look for but
normally they will dig rhizomes Linda
you see they are so cute but oh don't
worry don't worry [ __ ] much the agretti
layer but snacks yes they are so cute
but I can tell you we have seen lepers
going for them and anything called you
know coca-cola and any portend
Linda for a lipid including that scrub
here lavage will go for them as much as
they're cute and you feel sorry for them
when you see you know lepers is going
for them alright hope you got to see
more on the way or we might even see
something bigger
all right let's portray it all again oh
good [ __ ]
alright see some eyes on the road from a
distance maybes another one I don't know
how that is
oh is it a block let's get a little
closer there's a sandbox up [ __ ] oops
oh what's that [ __ ] stead Baca
maybe I'm the one that worried so before
those two of them hello Steinberg
we just seen some steam box before well
just walk in the grass there want to
cross the road hello there silly ears I
was talking about if if you look in the
ears like someone came with a paint or
with a feather and painted those ears I
have always it bad all right Taylor got
something more interesting
no I don't think more interesting just
cool I like a bush babies here we have a
bush baby sitting very very still look
I'm long it's Taylor's that's crazy
that's a little bit away from us which i
think is wise it is so relaxed I'm gonna
put the light on a just a little bit
just to help get a bit more sort of
detailed it was just so far away and
Craig seems to think this is the same
spot
we had an amazing sighting of a bush
baby Craig who were you with
he says Craig says he thinks it was
Ralph very nice I was a couple of
evenings ago wasn't it was just sitting
it's very relaxed that's a rock so I got
excited
I took the spotlight away I thought I
saw a mouse or a gerbil but I it wasn't
now it amazes me how sometimes you get
lucky and they just sit very very still
like this I'll give you an opportunity
to of course get a little screen shot
very nice anaconda tell their tales
almost double the length of the entire
body looks like it's not even looking at
us it's focusing at something else maybe
it's seen an insect or something moving
around on a branch and it's going to
pounce towards it is that the case
although is we going to winter there
tend to feed on a lot more gum of trees
the lesser galagos cuz they're all the
answer many insects around as we've
clearly seen see how it keeps focusing
so it's obviously just sitting there
waiting for an opportunity for a month
to maybe fly by and reach out and grab
it or the katydid to land on a perch on
one of these branches a couple of
insects flying around that you can see
the light catches every now and then but
not super substantial meal for I can't
ago thing they prefer to eat some bigger
insects rather than catching something
the size of the size of a midge like
eating a raisin very cool that's really
really awesome and what we're gonna do
you know let's take a gamble here and
it's driving little bit further forward
we've
had a nice sighting let's see if we can
get another view in the last few seconds
of the show me try roll win no I'm gonna
try find it again
it was here nah no I don't know where it
is
it's very difficult II see where it was
sorry I'm just scanning around oh maybe
that wasn't the best idea
oh well it's still quite cool don't you
think I think so nice long sighting of a
bush baby comparison to what we normally
see oh no we get the final countdown
anyways hope you enjoyed the safari
hopefully the cats will come out to play
tomorrow morning but have a great day
and we'll see you all on the sunrise
you